greetings from podcast Ville welcome to
sober October you ready for this one
that's my [__] idea scope October you
can call me sure you don't say the
podcast is brought to you by listen now
it's running a tremendous contest right
now you by alpha brain 30 count for 90
counts you're gonna take it a lottery
ticket you're gonna automatically win a
coupon let some beef jerky but they're
gonna empty you for the honor experience
gonna calm right now press the church
spam and get 10% off your order
delivered right to you half the best
supplement in the [__] world you
understand me number two the podcast is
brought to you by my family I would add
in Chicago they all came to the show CBD
Lyon dot-com the goods whether its
shadow whether its attention whether
it's the gummi bears
let me tell you something you can't go
wrong with CBD Lyon calm go to see the
BD line calm and press in church BAM get
20% of you order delivered to your house
number three listen I don't know what
week it is but with just a couple weeks
into pro football and there's no better
time to bet if you had the [__]
Tampa Bay Buccaneers yesterday you won
you [__] you're like winning
money who doesn't the Cowboys didn't
cover the Cowboys didn't cover New
England pushed it was a [__] disaster
yesterday if you're trying to bet on the
NFL baseball MMA whatever the [__] this
week you got UFC the Australian against
[__] the little African blue my
bookies got to fight not to mention the
NHL and NBA seasons all right around the
corner right now today you're double
your first deposit now today
use promo code Church CH you are CH to
get a hundred percent bonus on your
initial deposit up to $1,000 who does
that for you nobody your uncle Joey
that's [__] so visit my bookie
online today that's my bookie grab a pen
see it dumb [__] my B oh okay ie Sesame
Street [__]
and don't forget to use the promo code
Church when creating your account to
claim the bonus at my book e dot AG all
right you bet you win you get paid kick
this [__] mule lease is happy
Rosh Hashanah to you [__] uncle
Joey here direct if you came for the
Chicago show at the Chicago T that I
love you at all my heart thank you very
much for showing up if you went to any
how is your favorite shows embraer this
past weekend I thank you very much for
supporting us yeah thank you
we love that he got our backs and
whatnot but it's [__] October I
heard that Chicago sure was not it was
great they were great the theaters are
great theater I didn't completely settle
up it wasn't about that it was about
[__] doing a good show yeah I only
booked that so all my energy went into
that how was it it was tremendous yeah
you know listen that's we're all very
fortunate yeah to still be in the game
yeah never mind selling a ticket or two
we're very fortunate one other cruise
ship headed to [__] Norway cracking
jokes were a bunch of people with
coupons you know I'm saying so I give
thanks every morning when I wake up I
know you do and Lee does we're very
thankful you know they even be a part of
this [__] machine so yeah I don't
give a [__] about me having hard Louis
CK Amy Schumer I'm just happy to putt so
long be a dead do podcast twice a week
and talk to people like you we go to the
store on Tuesday night it's like a
little [__] mafia reunion on Tuesday
night it's where they yeah I'm surprised
the cops don't write the joint on
Tuesday just like let's go get all you
killers out of this [__] place yeah
all want it you can't commiserate you're
gonna share [__] secrets about
Netflix and [__] what's going on my man
I don't know what here it is for sobaco
but what do you want lay it out for me
so no drinking no smoking no sucky no
[__] be what's going on yeah nothing
nothing nothing
and I don't know I don't understand it
doesn't do anything for for a [__]
Bert I don't understand what we're doing
anymore
I hate it why do you hate it because I
hate it
Joey it's a time of
and the Jewish people love that [__]
they take a week off
it is the right around the time Potomac
it's on Yom Kippur so it's a time of at
home and take the month off Wow if I
wish if I could do it yeah I would do it
well step what does that mean well is
that most I mean if you could do it I'm
not strong enough to do it
I don't like rules like yeah I mean
either made me want to do stuff when it
comes up what made me go crazy when I
was in the halfway house was the rules
you telling me I can't do it if you just
say Joey
knock it off for a few days yeah I can
knock off weed for 3-4 days but at this
point my life it's become a teddy bear
it's become something I do in the
morning to wake up and eat and it's not
that I smoked pot all day I don't give a
[__] about what 20 I don't know [__]
about the movement I'm smoking dope
before that movement and movements over
I go everywhere now vapors I don't do
nothing I don't want to burn nothing
with a blowtorch
I just want to smoke a [__] join the
paper speaking of which what happened
but I joined so I look at water you try
to hide it on Rosh Hashanah no that's
okay I'm looking like it's a museum yeah
I want you to [__] light it what's
going on what you doing
it's good to be here dude I've been in
Hell a Mexican food like every day
there's a taco truck bison moans I go
[__] nuts
it's a that or in and out every time in
the right home I'm getting fat out here
there's no good Mexican like that in LA
and New York I mean I'm getting [__]
fat was a way that you're not walking
but yeah now maybe a little bit too for
sure can you believe it's gonna be 93
degrees in New York
is it really a new degrees or something
like that today it's supposed to be 90
[__] yeah that's why I Tober so [__]
nice I've got a huge snowstorm and
[__] Montana yeah foot and a half of
snow when you're here can its it the
truth like you can't even understand how
people could be under snow like you walk
outside and shorts and then you're like
you see on Twitter people like this this
place covered in snow and you're like
what these tents we're from the east
coast may be different I get to me it's
weird when I see them at 60 degrees
wearing like beanies and
winter coats and it is colder but that's
what's weird for me I tell you what
what's the problem I was telling my wife
this the other day we are as much as we
hate to say it living California except
for the traffic and the food we are
completely spoiled we walk out of our
house eight days out of ten and the Sun
is [__] just gorgeous gorgeous just
gorgeous it's naughty it's something
that you cannot even describe yes it's
expensive to pay and live here yes
there's traffic yes the gas is $4 a
gallon you put weight on yeah on the
worst day you'll never freeze to death
outside no that'll never ever happen no
no no no I mean it gets hot here like
September's the hottest note that's it
it talked downhill after tomorrow
tomorrow is a little sweatshirt it's
already starting to get cold it started
getting cold at night let me keep a
hoodie in your car but do you ever look
at the weather out here I don't look at
the weather you know I don't think I've
ever know how we take it for granted I
lived in two of the best places on the
country I live in Boulder Colorado
yeah 13 years and I've been here for 22
I'm pretty [__] damn fortune smoke
the thing of hamper lately it's sitting
there like it's a bug you looking at it
smoke it 'smoke that [__] thing it's
the last letter almost all this by my
same opening that's a boy you need to
smoke more do for the works done dick
people asking us to get high and I tell
them we don't want to do it no more it
gets wrong try this it brings cough drop
speaking of which it's time no way I
already took so much more than I ever
showed her how many points did you take
tonight that was tough - that was that
was not that was so many hold on we
didn't know I 1050 2012 a lot what's
five with five points five points is
heroin and a coke you your tolerance
that's why edibles is a particle your
tolerance is crazy nobody let no cocaine
nobody let no part we did a couple
[__] do two routes people no we did
great
and a black just note that we did
something all right how much the lows
count for man - I'm saying if I do - ooh
- newts that'll be too much you wait you
wait two or one - which one's the
edibles near the other thing the edibles
oh okay so that's hot - two loops oh
that's an edible two - Lutz's big pharma
oh okay okay so we did some pills from
Big Pharma legal is a [__] oh we
couldn't get the Duncan dust you cannot
know I couldn't get their [__] I
wouldn't have done the coke behind the
[Laughter]
thing I lose everybody check and not
even just left it there from and I think
of it so much I won't leave it on the
table I probably forgot it I told my
wife I wasn't oh you don't know how many
things I lose and fine I'm an old
[__] man let's get down to the basic
yeah I'm an old [__] man I've been
finding [__] lately yeah I even forgot I
had that little pin about toys
I found that and I swear to god I'm not
three weeks ago I was going through my
closet and I found the jacket yeah honey
full of roots of game they send me a
bunch of great t-shirts and stuff and
it's like I don't know what type of
jacket the second Muhammad Ali jacket
and I saw a baggie sticking out of the
pocket every of four different pills and
then there's an Altoid thing in there
with these [__] other pills so I
called my buddy and I asked him what
those bills when he told me what they
were I knew what the other skinny white
ones were yeah my buddy always gives
them to me when I go to New York he
gives me like that oh yeah
and I put him in a pocket I figured I
even have this [__] like I just forget
nobody [__] containers a week - that
was for a notebook yeah for the one man
John book and I found that a of [__]
that'll kill a normal human forgets they
have in their house I just forgot that
four seasons it was still fresh I don't
either
but I forget [__] all the time
never find something's just like where
do I get this from I got it if I can
make a memory I'll know if it's DMT or
MDMA I still got the Molly from the
other day do you know that's not a
squeezing your own titties okay so
you're rubbing yourself down the whole
thing wobble bad when you gave me this
the other birds they took it on I put it
in the drawer yeah just a draw it's been
pretend tonight when I went looking for
it while I was looking for that I found
three other things I found like another
whorfin pill I found like [__] what's
that was candy okay just straight candy
just still there's just candy we'll give
it to those small boy do you ever get
nervous that you're gonna forget
something you know like a airport bag
like AIT's just a dog before to get to
roll in papers I went in my suitcase
and I have a baggie that just has like
totally bad news [__] an extra tube you
know just in case something breaks down
let's trap him I sleep apnea mask up
next a toothbrush you know just stupid
[__] extra recall those things for your
phone what
Turner charger yeah I got [__] video
cha I got everything in there you know
and I found [__] a weed it's the best
two grams a [__] this great we've I
was wondering what happened to it
this weed I took on the road and I
rolled it in joints I was having heart
attacks outside I don't know what the
[__] I was Chicago Dallas I think I was
in Dallas well I went to Dallas I
brought this weed it's been in there for
[__] a month so what are you taking
it with you what do you got there my
friend
um oh [__] normally health candies how
many points is that points have we done
how many points for a bond him one right
yeah at least one whoa yeah
so we you with two and then we share the
joint that's three yeah and then what
else is doing yeah two two two two roots
count for four or five six four points
apiece so I did two that's eight other
points are like three no there's no way
cuz no I'm gonna take 200 milligrams off
your lip yeah no that's gonna check yeah
200 milligrams is big points on yeah I
think it was one point for 25 milligrams
one point for 25 milligrams yeah
one point for 25 milligrams yeah you
want to snort this Molly Leland oh I
don't know what that is but whatever you
good points dude have been more drugs
this year than I've ever done you left
edibles off I did leave an open soft
cause it's all about the tolerance for
edibles so if one bowl is one point has
to be at least be a point of milligram
right I'm gonna point away five
milligrams one no way every 5 min every
10 milligrams for you 50
Oh for you a hundred I get a hundred mil
okay
one point prawn point oh no it's there
okay fifty that's not that fair I guess
that's two four points what is it wonder
his points just points need to be
adjusted then three points because they
don't do nothing community do not fit to
you you were just load up its
gentleman's game yeah I'm eating listen
let me face I started with this no no
leave it there for the roaches yeah
[__] eat it first off this ABX
extract is available
I love these edible yeah it's like the
best Idol boy everything is you know why
why it's clean Bobby there's no sugar
there's no cookie there's no brownie you
know what hanging when you drink booze
it's not the alcohol I get you all it's
the sugar is that true yeah it's the
sugar like when you join give a quadric
like when you're colada is one man gonna
ham it the next day you wake up feeling
like that yeah you got a headache from
the hangover but you overdosed your body
with sugar like when I would go to Miami
I would drink those ABS don't stings are
all sugar
so we medicals Jesus Lee and I we took
cookies at night you're gonna be a fat
[__] and then eating the [__] eye
tonight I feel bad for what's in my
kitchen everything's going to what is
you read everything yeah you start with
apples you try to be nice
you start with apples Maxine are you in
peanut butter and saltines and catnip
it's a [__] nightmare
oh yeah [__] well crushing the points
tonight people so bark Toba starts to
tomorrow
it's Monday the 30th whenever the 31st
it don't matter we're going deeper
there's a real All Hallows Eve [__] yeah
tonight's the second night of Rosh
Hashanah what usually happens ha same
thing a forgiveness you get got buttered
up
Russians when you get got buttered up he
opens the books from Russia Shia and
then he's like thinking about it for
about 10 days and then you know keep or
you [__] close though so right now is
when you're like ok member we've been
having a good year you know and I
started asking forgiveness from
everybody hey don't let it when it goes
judgement time
forgive me for everything I've done to
you
saying like Sam yeah forgive you
and then like so gods like are take that
out take that out you know and then they
just judged you for everything so your
the whole time like come on come on go
easy on me please please I love you you
know and he's like alright and then by
the yom kippur boom he shot and then
that your fate of seals for the year I
love that yeah nothing nothing I'd love
more when somebody tells you history or
religious and they put it into their own
words and they put human to it yeah
like what really [__] had like I had
a buddy that that was his specialty he
knew everything about everything when it
came to history so when he tell you
about my car during this he would tell
you in a comical way and it made more
sense yeah yeah yeah what a [__]
professor tells you with that [__]
dramatic voice during class but that's
pretty interesting in this new I watched
you xx the story in that it's very
oh it's all that's a Jewish yeah it's
like laughs you know yeah well a lot of
people haven't been down this the last
20 is very interesting yeah I try to do
it are getting like you said like a
normal way you know where it's just like
real like this is really what's
happening you know not like you have to
say this prayer but like it's pretty
much just like come on go easy on us
it's like you know that's really what it
is
and when you're in New York and he Jews
come up to you a little on the hard side
and say something oh they love it they
love it almost always they love it once
in a while they'll say something but
usually they love it and if they say
especially the religious girls I see the
girls in the wigs and they come out and
I keep an eye on it when I'm going up in
New York in Manhattan there's frontier
juice the frontier Jews come out those
are like top of the line like I'm not
supposed to go here but it's not illegal
you know so they even have the [__] and
all the things and they'll like I'll go
out to a comedy club you know and uh and
so once a while I see him and then I
wait for him especially the girls when I
talk about girl stuff they die laughing
because somebody's finally including him
I think you know yeah but once in a
while people like who don't you aren't
you worried about them coming after us
like nothing really cool no I think some
people with every every 20 shows yeah
this guy
one guy after a show that says maybe
yeah maybe probably that usually know if
I can't walk out this cuz I'm too dirty
it's usually that how can you go walk
out I don't know sometimes you remember
people like they're not even angry
they're just like business just not for
me this is like a lot more [__] I
thought they'd go in thinking probably
one to zero [__] and then once four
minutes goes into the opener already
like oh my gosh who's the person you'd
ever seen the most walked out snog most
walkouts dice forget a lot where after
store the store people were just like
yeah I loved it he loved he said he got
walkouts in his Vegas shows people like
that's it's only for him you know he's
not like popping in people are still
like hi I didn't know it would be like
this I think you gotta get a couple of
walkouts or you're not doing your job a
couple you can't be for everybody you
know a delay say something Misha [__] I
say about [__] what's the name Rose
McGowan yeah she's you know that's not
appropriate joke I say you know I'm done
with that bothered me last week the
thing about that kid was sign that
morning nothing that bothered me for the
but I didn't bother me or anger me it
just bothers me but the future economic
snow and what they're thinking of what
they're being what's being said to them
and how that's really gonna change the
face economy of people who just really
want to go up to incise them yeah hey no
wait times came up and circulated on
Twitter the Facebook I read and they
spoke about the Comedy Store and thought
let me tell you something and Ari knows
on Sunday nights I had intensive talks I
used to have intensive talks yeah yeah
but it's at a time and it was horrible
because there was a comic on stage but
she'd talk to me and she'd tell me
I come up there with fluff she called
the white flower for something she
didn't like it she wanted you to be
yourself yeah she wanted you to say
whatever the [__] you want to say
nothing was taboo up there I mean
remember watching tennis in the first
time ago Wow wait does that joke about
the [__] people live out the sand and
he's like you know where humanitarian we
try to help you want you go somewhere
wish it grows you're in the [__]
desert
[Music]
wow that's what she wants she Mitzi sure
wanted raucous Mitzi sure yeah she'd
like to rock us make sure she sure
wanted you to create ruckus if you watch
Kennison like that you've never seen
that about the sand well let you grow
once or what gently it's pulled off a
fun video about the sand something about
doesn't grow here that one giving them
it on aid who oh it's Kennison chemist
oh yeah yeah yeah I got an idea go to
where the [__] say yeah yeah don't go
in the sand is all that [__] yeah that's
to me that was the most taboo [__] ever
[__] yeah that and Richard Pryor was it
something I said that the [__] crazy
oh really crazy should have heard Jesus
on the railroad depot when he told Jesus
not to go down there messing with them
Jews ah how money I heard that 72 is
hong-won I was a kid I almost died
Dunkel he was I made I met Jesus down
the railroad death pole I told that
[__] don't go down there messing
with those Jews or not no money
that's a [__] funny [__] joke so
how do you or do I guess baby doesn't
matter but so if you if you that works
at the store there's a lot of clubs
where they're gonna go they're gonna
freak out if you say so
nowadays oh no they're not because of me
sure wanted from you was to keep working
on that bit so when you do go on the
road that joke comes off just like
you're the original right now the
training I did the last year at the mine
Netflix debacle which had said a
thousand times it's just a train at the
Comedy Store I was wasting my time doing
spots everywhere else I'm a marine why
am I going to hanging out with the Air
Force guys or [__] marine why am I
going over to this club and and I was
[__] army [__] whatever they're
medics well I was raised to be a killer
Mitzi shore created killers that was you
know I wanted look at her resume when
you watch those Rodney tapes there were
all her killers there were handcrafted
killers that's what she wanted you to be
that's why whenever people in the bind
they go to the Comi store you want to
find [__] talent to do a project you
look at that [__] Tommy Store yeah
there's a chick there's an old man a
young guy a Chinese guy a black side
there's everything you need rolled up on
one [__] stop you know and that's
what she that's what after the Netflix
thing I was like I'm wasting my time
with all this [__] nobody wants a
hit Joey Diaz talking about his daughter
yeah here or there but nobody that's not
what I'm about
I mean if I am gonna talk about my
daughter it's something in that you know
the world we live in today how I'm
raisin in the world we live in I don't
give a [__] about what they're telling
me I'm raised I'm telling you how to
raise a [__] kid so they're better
than everybody else cuz nobody else is
raising that kids no with that kind of
integrity kids losing their minds all
the [__] time I'm around them more now
more than ever I'm like wow who the
[__] raising this kid a nanny so I see
the [__] whatever you know but I don't
I don't how can you fire me from a TV
show because that put something on
Twitter what about the guy kidnapped er
is it [__] they call it the canceled
culture so what are you gonna cancel
what are you gonna cancel on us a gig
where unless you rape somebody or you
[__] even if you take your dick out
now louis c.k proved you still selling
out yeah so you got a rape the [__] and
get caught with the [__] kid you know
23andme 'he's got to be there with the
[__] [__] and then you got you got
you know like if you [__] even sexual
harassment they give you a little break
now they push it back in
yeah even what's his name his back ari
from [__] giant pivot yeah I seen him
around yeah you know what he's doing
stand-up yeah but they gave him a series
or a movie they put him in the really
yeah he's in the back yeah yeah they you
back in the you know everybody get
listen how bad did you know that Harvey
Weinstein is out like around town you
see who was a waitress he came in and
she was like none of the waitress is
like way we don't really want to serve
him and they were like you have to and
they were like we don't really wanna
yeah like this buckets that we don't
like that guy so everybody's just out
going out what you gonna do well I guess
I always thought he was like gone and
I'm know he's in New York right if I
guess oh yeah he's in New York he's in a
safe haven yeah he goes to a temple once
a week can you imagine if you were
sitting at one of those like at like
communal tables when you go out of one
of those small places and you have to
just sit next to other people and then
Harvey Weinstein is right next to your
imagine like 10 minutes he'll pick the
best you know what believe it was just
one extra one time see suck my dick like
you wanted about Jake you don't think
you'd stay in your house I would stay in
my house I would for a while I guess I
wonder hey Lewis CK and what what do you
feel like what do you go through how
long can you stay at the house but I get
fidgety after like a couple days with
three or four yeah I get three or four
days over now let me give you another
sign yeah I have it to her for a month
after I got out of [__] County Jam
yeah what what prison you feel like
you go to the supermarket that chick
knows you are in jail you go to the gas
station the [__] guy knows you're in
jail in your mind so I can't imagine
being louis c.k you know who got all
this [__] taken from one day of being
Harvey Weinstein who got everything
taken from me what do you do what do you
do in in Louis CK's situation what do
you do exactly what he dropped off the
face of the earth for a month or two and
then he said what I can't stay in this
[__] house you kind of go out I gotta
go and they took him back at the at the
Comedy Cellar yeah they accept him back
so that's it little by little he didn't
bother nobody
somebody tried to [__] with him along
the way and tape all of his cents but he
was working out [__] and they made a big
deal about it for no [__] reason and
he's back he just said not to rant
though you know there was an article if
away that he doesn't want tape record
there's nobody taking notes you know
whatever everybody has their own thing
but we've become the judge the jury
what's that expression and execution
electrocution you ever see one of those
things where ever gets mad about some
and you're just like in your head you're
like I don't even see what you guys are
even talking about I don't see what you
like what like sometimes you're like is
this the right reaction this is the
wrong reaction and then other times
you're like wait I'm not even trying to
see where you guys ever talk I couldn't
even talk about it seems like a [__]
made-up anger sometimes you know where
it's like as the bus drove yeah he's for
no reason look at this guy the prime
minister trudeau okay
take a look at this poor bass lines now
he's sitting there at home six months
ago watching World News Tonight just
like my [__] flat ass and he's
watching but that guy went through in
Georgia in college he [__] him put on
blackface and they tried to accuse him
now then the guy was like man not only
that I put on blackface one time for
Michael Jackson look who said that the
governor of Georgia oh yeah yeah you
know and he didn't mean you could tell
you had no [__] anguish in his heart
again they tried to blow it up I don't
know who was there
right little hum you know what that
means but then you got a guy like true
donut sitting at home that jerk-off sees
this instead of going hey you know what
going to his defense and going hey you
know what years ago I got drunk and some
chicken foot blackface on me and release
those photos look what he went through
last week
yeah is that his story that he got drunk
and I don't know but I'd rather go to
the punch before they do what do you
mean go to the punch Jack dead before
they do they're gonna find out yeah
listen you know what I'm sorry
Vinny Robin knocks on Yahoo they were
blackmailing him he's running for
governor of Jerusalem way back mayor of
Jerusalem and his opponent took a bunch
of pictures of him cheating on his wife
and sent it to him said drop out or
these go to the [__] press and then he
called a press conference himself with
his wife said this guy's blackmailing me
that's private matter [__] and he
[__] shot up and beat the guy that's
it yeah beat them before they don't feel
sure that's what that Jon Ronson book
says no the ones who don't actually feel
any shame it doesn't really touch them
listen if you nothing bothers me more
when you look at a guy and he's got
veins coming out of his neck and they
got pompous steroids at least telling
you didn't do yeah you hit 2200 months a
year 18 19 20 18 again
47 look you straight in the eye I'm in
telling you this I don't get mad at
those people yeah I feel bad for them
because this is what they have to do to
keep it together you know I've got tons
of skeletons a closet we all do yeah you
know if I feel I have pretty much
released pretty much all the skeletons
in my closet except a few aces I'm old
enough in case the judge needs to
renegotiate my escape to Nicaragua yeah
[Laughter]
how cuz I like your question is why not
just come out with it
like I see if I'm Trudeau and I see how
angry everyone's getting I'm like oh I
bet I forgot about it though yeah that's
[__] you guys should more black face
and like what about you know I never do
that and they're like remember this and
you'd be like Oh
yeah that's right I think everybody's
got some of those things like whatever
it wasn't a big deal nobody made a big
deal of it at the time and then he was
like he forgot about it who's so
inconsequential it wasn't like he was at
a Klan rally doing it you know he was
doing it out in public or no one would
thought it was a bad thing
what killed me about the thing would
sign that life was that the guy said
that he went back to episode 114 the guy
had said something right
so either when the guy got put on a
sinai alive he had listened to all his
stuff or he was somebody who put on that
podcast said [__] I'm offended or we
could play the poor kid gets bonus on
that live and he raised his hands do you
think it was that or do you think it's
someone like okay these are the people
who got SNL let me get one yeah the
fastest way to a good story is to just
get to get somebody so it but what did
you do did you listen to every [__]
yeah what quickly here's what I know
because he stopped I mean yeah if he
could have gotten way worse stuff but it
was like I'm sure you know when it was
like well he said this it was like well
I found something quickly go it's like
you're just rushing to try to hurt
somebody it's not your thing no it's not
for you don't listen to it it's
obviously not for you just don't listen
to it you're only coming here to be
angry what the [__] is wrong with you
it's like don't listen to it just don't
come it's hot they always get on comedy
it's in [__] 80-seat basements just
don't come here it's the smallest amount
of people obviously watching about three
months ago I would've told waitress at
the store yeah and we always hug now
kiss for years I see her and it's great
to see him about a couple of months ago
whenever I saw one I said today again I
beat it to the punch but she's a
sweetheart I remember that morning you
picked me up for radio I asked you for a
[__] like 20 times oh my god
you could have [__] said something
you know I didn't say anything I know
why she goes cuz you were the best one
of all
you were the Commish once I can name
names of guys ripping my shirt off damn
really you know you can comic at 6:00 in
the morning the radio he's coming down
off that [__] margin bust by five
o'clock he starts jerking off while
setting a single girl picture up do
ready you're throwing out all the curves
I don't even want to do is take your
dick out start whacking off in the car
Jesus I'm a white church I [__] him
snorted till she picked me up
really I wish we went to like three
radio stations have the last radio
station on my list I rock a lot come on
come on let's go back to the house I
heard you suck a tremendous dick
she had blown some other comic and I
heard about oh I can't
I haven't even had a drink yet but it
was like 6:00 at night now yeah yeah
[__] crazy and she said you know what
I think going back you one of the comics
one she names in vain really so does
that mean that like that stuff used to
work well because if you did it that
means like a certain amount of times
that kind of if you said that sir she'd
be like yeah I'll come over what a lot
of people don't understand is you can't
you can't put like a comedy club like
behave you can't judge it against an
office behavior right we hang out till
[__] 4:00 a.m. the place closes the
two we all hang out to a forty I'm doing
like drinking and doing coke that's like
it's not it's just a party every night
you're just part of you people are
hooking up left and right I mean not
really really I like everyday but like
you know we're all [__] young wannabe
comics wannabe actors and actresses you
know I didn't tell me for three years
before I got into a scene yeah do you
like when you fall into a scene I did I
started 91 and I knew comedians and I
say hello to them at different shows in
Denver but it wasn't till like late 93
that I got into like what you got into
98 by the door for that Saint 2004 any
Duncan
Bobby Lee you lived and died for one
another yeah yeah well we had money when
you got your first commercial you take
everybody to picked up the sandwiches
you never I lived and died for Bobby
tickets to Jerry's yeah like all that
type of [__] older Kalani's all that
nasty [__] that's around there but it's
weird I didn't get into that too like my
third year in comedy and it was a party
five nights a week darling what's up I
mean last week I yelled at you
you called me at five to town at home
I'm wait what are you doing home
all right it was a party every 91 years
old yeah every night it's a party every
night
after the third and a half year it's a
party you get together with it's six
guys and you go you know whatever the
mics and then you go straight to Jerry's
or some of your straight to somewhere
else or a diner and they go hang it up
yeah the one hours that Oberst bachelor
you talking about
and there's always four chicks in the
group gather the married one that just
broke up with a boyfriend yeah one do a
sake dick if you keep her out past three
o'clock
everybody's the well known she's already
done some of the comics and I'm not
putting those woman down no they say hey
they're great that a great society we're
in and when I was opening like every
year there was there was one girl two
out of every three years there was at
least somebody you could say like you
just look at her across the bar and she
look at you and just like not actually
just go you must go to the back that's
it that's it was such my knee
94-95 I was having such a great time in
Denver yeah I was part of a clique and
when they got a gig David and I was part
of like four clicks but one clique that
we were all the same and we had all been
doing comedy for three and a half years
maybe one guy was doing six years he was
featured already whoo like no it's
Jackie friend asked me to open from last
week at the Comedy Store that type of
[__] you know there was just a little
clique of you that clicked I don't know
with them from November of 93 the
children 95 who wasn't your clique at
that time Jeff sergeant Jimmy obey the
and the Paden this black dude there were
a couple chicks that would comic-style
me remember their names I don't even
know if they're doing it yeah you know I
was in with features and headliners I
was in with guys that we were beginning
to have one we're beginning to Fitch
feature Tribble once oh really
let you come back and we dog you
congratulations I was it you like oh my
god we've got a Boise you're like oh I
can't wait to go to Boise you know yeah
those are the people my point is that
you were with them right when I first
met you you ran with those guys still
for five more yeah but my those guys
were like open mics together we're New
Berlin hey we're better than these like
crazy people
yeah yeah I mean you guys had it going
on you guys worked at the store you guys
were tight I'll never forget that you
you had got a little quick analogy when
is easy just because I'm alone yeah the
Spanish get Rick Ramos almost yeah you
know this is nice this is like like
black like black Carboni painter painter
crushed painter changed everybody he was
so [__] dark we couldn't believe it
he was so he was like when you would do
the employee section it was like a
question if you go pre painter or post
painter cuz he would either destroy like
level the place where like no one else
could go on to that level of laughter
for like three more comics or he would
bomb so bad that like everyone in the
audience felt like weird for a while he
made like they saw something terrible so
I him to do some creepy stuff of him and
then I heard it was creepy offstage
no he just liked to [__] a lot right
yeah he like put it out there for
everybody he put it out there oddly very
Christian very Christian would not say
he'll say heck
dropping heck as 10 stories of like we
got into a big fight with Carboni about
they were watching a porn
it was early porn where there's not many
rules and there was a porn of a dog
eating out a girl a woman excuse me
she's my bad a woman they sold and on
the Internet it was just on the Internet
okay I don't know when like people had
passwords
stuff and uh disgusted by it I painter
was like um she's got nice tits Doug is
like that has nothing to do with the
quality of her tits screaming match over
it
that is disturbing Oh a woman I can't
watch that
okay watch that in the early days of the
you know like you would download
something it would say like regular porn
and the worst one I thought was like a
German Shepherd [__] lady from the
days of like LimeWire
oh yeah you have to download your porn
yeah this day like that so you get a
porn and you have it like hey let's
watch my porn I guess right oh my and
then yo should come around and giving
you boxes of Lord Yoshi it's like Yoshi
you already ate or you're coming in he's
like can we go through your car it's
like yeah neighbors and your CDs I had a
neighbor that I would give those we jump
up and down when I gave I don't watch
porn I don't know boy what Yoshi was
give me just give me this homemade [__]
some black guy [__] a white chick you
know she's she didn't want to be there I
don't want to watch that [__] I really
don't cause I can't I don't want to see
a [__] chick get me now buy a dog
even though if I had a crazy chick time
on my house and we were doing coke this
[__] I'd ask her like my dog eat your
[__] while I put my dick in your mouth
that would be a tremendous [__] video
really but they throw you in jail yeah I
don't know myself yeah hopefully another
Gebbie Muslim five-year-old anymore it
really has changed I don't wanna watch
I'd really help I don't want just come
across it I want to happen know what I'm
getting into look away when you see it
and suddenly it's that suddenly it's a
horse [__] video you're just like oh
you know you can't just look away so now
you're watching it like I'm gonna Rogen
at you all those years I never turn down
the video with a hoarse voice
it was disturbing the second time the
first time I get out work because it's
like your brain can't make sense of it
and then the second time you see it
about halfway through you're like oh
yeah then it all hits you look in the
middle and so then you're like the one
where he dies at the end he dies
afterwards allegedly no one really knows
that's what they said but you concede it
definitely that could have happened how
big was the horse's dick far bigger than
his ass no [__] it was like it was like
that it was about that but thicker it is
but about that long now he had a friend
with him
right see I wouldn't call that a friend
yeah yeah but the enemy I obviously he
went to some rogue without a bit about
that right well I had a hysterical bear
but looking back somebody calls you up
and says re can I meet you for coffee
and stuber's I have to run something by
you
yeah I feel like maybe he wants to
borrow money sure I'm always there for
you buddy buddy so let's talk you know
this uh-huh but I'm beyond gay you like
I don't go what do you mean in like how
you went to bondage not really do you
like the [__] groups not really I've
done it but I'm not so then what do you
mean by beyond gay title I went to
Pennsylvania with my friends from high
school yeah sure the homecoming when I
went on the [__] horse I noticed how
big his dick was and I'd taken a [__]
one time that was 18 to 19 inches and I
figured I could put the horse's dick up
my ass so that night I went when
everybody was sleeping I went unstable
and I Vaseline my ass I didn't eat no
lunch at dinner because I want to empty
stomach on purpose I purposefully and I
moved the horse up I went doggy style
was a [__] nightmare it was like
being in downward dog
oh and I had it going downward dog and
finally I got to dip in my [__] but I
don't know horses have some type of
infections so I end up in the hospital
and an infraction and I read up on it
online and OH in those days in the
cyclopædia online and you have to spit a
Cass Peschel shot
for horse to [__] you in the ass I mean
why you sit there go so what are we
getting that so yeah why'd you get me in
the back for this like the reason why I
need your force that we might look at I
want to go to this board I'm going you
for a long time
please don't share this with nobody else
no no right away you like well I got a
secret to tell you
couple nights ago I went home thank you
wow I licked it like how do I get myself
so now I just buy dogs that are
abandoned I haven't lick my balls when I
kill them drop on the corner so there's
no evidence you know this is too [__]
Minds this is true people that met and
you think about that it's like heroin
people in LA
like I did blow for 20 years no way and
I think a one person in 22 years of a
came up to me and said hey do you wanna
do heroin it was a chick you know
whatever that was crazy and I knew and I
was doing other drugs but heroin people
attract heroin people you do any heroin
I did it not with her that night I did
it a couple years afterwards what was it
like tremendous Oh tremendous and I told
the story on your [__] show yeah but
which one went the gun to his house and
he gave me a wine a white heron why I
sold them me and didi sold him while
like a TV right no was a tablet to put
dishes and he was a be non-elected an
arm was that well I think that's why I'm
wrong yeah and we went over there and we
went over the afternoon Gunther Brown
looked just like Tony I don't mean he
was a pervert and I didn't know he was a
pervert to that day he Kanta he'll be
like ass and they were Sunday and he
answered the door with a robot you know
and no shoes on just a robot it's like
what's up I don't know if you want to
buy this and he goes ahead looks
interesting oh yeah I know you like
those type of pieces then he was I'm
kind of busy right now can you come back
in a few hours and I'll square with you
because make it like 8 o'clock I'm like
[__] I thought this is not gonna pay me
but I knew got that money got that
family money he lived on the corner next
to this family
the Denny's but what just as crazy they
have like three boys and their sister
one of them were twins she was twins of
Mike who was my buddy and he was a
[__] nightmare I have called him the
devil he's in jail right now for killing
his wife in North Carolina they we were
kids we call them the devil like when
they call you the devil when you're 15
you got problems oh yeah and people
would say where you goin I'm going to
this place with Denny you will hang out
with the devil like that's how bad he
was I was always something always
something with Mike Denny then he had a
brother who had a fire played the guitar
he had fake teeth and they had a long
hand he thought he was Jimmy Page but in
real life he had a chick dime the man he
would just tell her suck his dick what
she would suck your dicks in one man he
took her to a party in my hometown my
Junie I was not there and she sucked
like 18 dick so they called the marathon
woman but now there was a big push a lot
like wow these guys got too tired let's
break that rented let's break that
record and they took her back to a house
by Franklin school one night Jimmy Denny
was his name and this chick loves to
suck 20 Thaksin broke a record how is
not around and the next day they kept
all the marathon woman at school
marathon woman I mean in everybody knew
and she walked around with nothing
happened yeah and thinking back now you
could see she was crazy looking yeah I
was good looking
it was good looking and yeah matter of
fact but look thinking back you can see
it there was something wrong there at an
early age she was 17 18 that's where we
see a crazy person they still have their
looks and then yourse I can't make sense
of it you know like oh you're about
you're gonna be homeless in like a year
you know or it's like you're on just in
the very beginnings of crazy and it's
like it's all gonna go to [__] that was
a crazy [__] label do you ever hear
what happened to her
Marathon woman no really bleep you look
like somebody Jew you and then stopped
when they got to the eyes yeah that's
how I feel
they I know and I saw her high school I
remember high school picture the
yearbook picture really disturbed me
realize she wanted like she had a saying
I'm not a name like it was like her name
but of all the people on that whole list
she put like a saying all right what was
her live forever or something like I you
gonna [__] be 28 tell your husband you
suck 40 [__] junior in high school
that is probably with something that
wouldn't she probably sucked dirty [__]
because there was dudes over there for
seconds but there was there was a ton of
dudes talking about as I say she would
swallow - yeah one load she had a
stomach ache for a week ha ha ha but
getting back to dr. Brown so night I
went over there without didi I remember
going in he gave me the 60 [__] was
didi didi was a crazy friend of mine
he's still around now I just talked to
him last week he moved from the shore
back up north with his brother good
friend of mine solid and his brother
with dear friends of mine he told me I
had the fact I told the reason beanie
wasn't with me because that guy got to
live close to me and I was headed to Dee
Dee's and we're going to Dedes to get
coke afterward when I go back on time he
says come and come and he's still got a
robot there's beer bottles everywhere
and he's like sit around go saying
listen to this I remember what Zeppelin
why it was not fly about the garden and
we were just talking to and me on he
just gave me a beer I don't know he was
lonely in the middle of conversation he
was listening does it check back there
the bathroom she's passed out there was
drugs all [__] day if you want to
suck dick why you sit on the toilet and
I'm like that's okay is the crazy thing
guys that I'm a young man
I may be 17 my mother was dead no and
like when you're 17 you'll take a
[__] from a man from anything you'll
take a [__]
right in it yeah well he was like she's
passed out in the bathroom I'll wake her
up he won't you dicks up I'm like no
that's okay that's how scary it was all
right and he was an avid Beatle
collector
what was the part that freaked you out
like what like the chick passed out the
[__] bathroom well sometimes just
leaps in like a sexual experience you're
like I'm not ready for this [__]
leave I wasn't ready for that I was
ready
Lenalee when I was 17 I had hopes and
dreams so they would I would go you know
go and throw roses up in the air
somebody was on the second I didn't
think I was gonna get my dick sucked on
the street of dirty Jake that I don't
have the toilet that's just you wanted
but she won't actually turn her on to
suck your dick while you sat in the
toilet and I go no that's okay and I go
I'm thinking about and he goes no sit
around waving you want to align a cup we
didn't want a coke I think we started
talking about music and he goes you
would do I don't know it right there I
knew he was going to ask me I just know
it you know when you get that ball on
your neck anyway [__] not between you
and I at that age this is something that
even though I didn't want to live
anymore because I didn't have a mother
yeah I didn't want to go out by arrow
you know saying well I don't mind
getting [__] up and getting hit by a
car I'll be getting [__] up and
jumping off a bridge
but Dinah Hamlin I just didn't want that
on my racket I just didn't want that
tarnish as crazy as it sounds yeah my
mother's way he's like you wanna do
alright just a little line in the song
so make sure I got well I did it I don't
know remember if I got sick I think I
got sick but I didn't trip like when I
told the story on your show people
yelling at me the next day like you know
trip on alright that's some heroin but
it was something like you just feel this
[__] lump in your stomach my body
went numb I felt like you know before
you feel like before you have surgery
yeah that feeling that everything's
funny in like everything's distant and
then I went out I went somewhere like I
went somewhere for a while and then I
came back and I started going in and out
of it and it was just a tiny bit but I
had never done it before
you know I don't remember if I did get
sick now cuz I got sick a bunch of times
doing
stuff you always puke when you do that
and that's when it kicks in
what's your puke oh really yeah that
Chinese heroin from Chinatown it kicks
him once you puke
once you puke that's when you know like
that's what I heard Wow
oh yeah yeah the heroin yeah that's was
something that was the first time and I
remember like I felt really shitty about
myself that my long walking home I don't
know that [__] was a long [__] time
ago and I didn't do heroin again till I
was locked up I live you know how did it
feel when you were on it though that
night yeah my comas getting [__] up
every night those days at that age I was
getting hosed or something yeah how old
seventeen sixteen like I still love a
snow angel dust like take a little ass
and going home like a 10 o'clock and
like [__] having a nervous breakdown
yeah watching TV and The Exorcist was on
me turning it off [__] this master
reality I'm like all that [__] was too
heavy for my little seventeen-year-old
mind but so I didn't do it again so I
want the prison at that time it really
didn't work because they had a melt
Mexican heroin into my nose and I don't
dude when it comes like a goop so they
had to melt it down to a liquid and then
they scooped it up with like a dropper
and I had to bend my head back and they
bothered my nose cuz I know I want to
shoot it I'm a [__] I don't wanna know
why does that seem worse I know I don't
know listen when you're young oh that's
Stan Shubin yeah yeah oh my god I can't
imagine okay
oh my nose I dropped it in my nose like
this this Brown tasting [__] oh I don't
remember if anything happened and then
in 93 in New York I did a wine with my
brother and I [__] me up and the next
morning he told me was you don't know
wine that could have killed the horse
thanks for telling me
haha
touch you again till 2007 really and how
does that do that was it I would get
[__] up like three four hours I would
just pass out punished Li it damn crazy
you know they it's so Brock dope I could
save that [__] for next month - right
so what's your plan when do you start
missing reefer I'll probably start on
behind us it I've been enjoying it in LA
smoking in the car I went to in and out
and the guy was taking my cash he was
like damn that smells good I was like
yeah that's good you just sit in line
and just like smoke was in the radio
dude I got home yesterday I put my car
in I smoked some new songs on the radio
and I just pulled in and just listening
to radio I didn't even like move I
didn't turn the car off for like 40
minutes I just sat it was in the radio
well hey Rob you know I don't want to
smoke weed the car drive you do know
that - look Troy when when who said that
I got a new tax no someone no it said
that who said that no that's not a real
no they have to first of all they have
to catch you which is not gonna happen
because I'm an excellent speed driver
and I'm on the we'd do a Ludum aluminum
arrive just get to an underpass you
gotta get to underpass that's where you
lose them the helicopters gotcha you got
to get to a garage of some kind
they can't bash you so you take the
ticket right the thing goes up then you
ease ease when the thing goes down then
they have to take a ticket otherwise and
then you can quickly go get out of that
car and [__] bolt
well [__] ticket you talk a little
that's take it to let you into the
garage yeah you want you to we saw car
chase yesterday what you have to do is
you have to get to where ok the
helicopter scotches you got to get off
from where they can see you right
ok the helicopters got a [__] spotter
I don't know that great so you got to go
underground of some kind
at a garage there's a thing that comes
up to let you into the garage you're
gonna get in one of those take the
ticket and then when the thing goes down
as you go then the cop behind you now
he's gotta wait a second he's gotta get
a ticket and things go up you take that
15 seconds
bolt go
and then jump out that car put in a spot
jump out run somewhere else and that's
your only shot that's your only shot
how are they gonna lock down the whole
building or do they know what you look
like I don't think so I did that already
well how is it not gonna work because
they'll sit and wait and baby in that
area what you're in the office building
I'm just here everybody Harker stored
off his building if you escape by the
Holloway they bring the [__] dog and
that dog get you something they start
sniffing around oh [__] there's so many
houses to get where the car is they see
yeah oh you did they can ascend time
plus you if it's your car they know who
you are and if you stop your car it's
not your car oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
they would get you I don't figure you
would a rental car you still haven't put
your car down yeah I think is this so
this is my thing they've given us the
gift a leather smoke yeah they giving
you the gift of us going to a store yeah
the least we could do is say you know
what I'm not like I don't like smoking
in my car I don't wake it in the car if
I get pulled over I got no leg to stand
up on I'm dead and now they have a test
so you get pulled over you got red eyes
they got like a litmus test really what
some swiping your tongue or there's
something so those days of long time Wow
you gotta provide Zenon your eyes I mean
well you can't afford a [__] DUI
right now why this would be the perfect
time to get one no I don't try very much
it would be the perfect time to get do
you want to lose your driving privilege
I know but of all the times to get it
when I live in a city where I don't need
it it's a helpful time it's a [__]
horrible we live in an age of uber it's
a horrible blemish on you that's true
it's 2000 out now specific it's 2019
I over here you know that's what I'm
saying if you get a DUI in today's
society your [__] you should be shot
your [__]
cuz it's everywhere yeah brother long
time Lube oh no boom sorry a DUI you
gotta go to classes oh I'm just saying
alright your brother-in-law everybody's
brother-in-law got a [__] DUI that
loan for his podcast he's a [__]
loser and he drank one night and he
[__] got a D yeah you're not 22 and
now
got to pay a fine he's got to take
classes
he got points on his license there's a
new bar it goes up that's why it was so
[__] pop it reminds me though over
the Kinnison bit and the question is but
what are you gonna do with your car how
are you gonna your car home you got to
just say like I'm to come maybe I'll get
a ticket
what do you mean like it let's say you
drove somewhere and then you serve doing
hello drugs and you got to get home
people always I put my cars on the
street I can't leave that in the morning
we'll figure that out when we burn that
bridge when we get to it
well for right now shut your mouth do
the coke and let's enjoy the evening I
will figure that out the morning maybe
the dentist will leave out of his spot
we'll put you in the building I did too
much tonight already what you do we
stick I think another Hannibal no no no
well I already realize I hate more than
it well running life here gentlemen I'm
sorry this is a light night 200
milligrams well you ready it's the
mixing it's the problem what makes it
we've got a couple good salutes about no
but Kobe looking at bring beer what I
even got CBD or the comude done if
anybody loses their know anything it
starts twitching let me know I got my
CBD off from CBD behind calm when are
you gonna get a heroin sponsor I'm
talking the vision of Isis a dealer
distributors everything the jingle the
whole thing I could see you in an opium
den like an old Chinatown opium den I
can see you just down there and I'd be
that have you and Duncan why don't know
why don't one on the right hahahahahah
shoes off get a foot rub with Chinese
woman no Chinese guy come she smoked
opium with him you start hallucinating
he puts a tower and you were cold water
does it's gonna be alright with a cold
towel gonna be alright you start
sweating profusely they've been rice
back on your neck did I see those guys
in New York gacked out you ever see them
yeah they [__] on heroin oh yeah I
guess I don't know is that heroin yeah
dumped to their
over there all the way over her head
almost hits the ground but it doesn't
hit the ground or they're standing up
and they're bent over and they look it
up [__] human question mark they're
just like I missed and kind of question
is that big in New York again yeah and
then just stand where the village or in
the west side of the eastside village
west side a lot of near NYU a little
unrelated I think but like what's a
college there's got to be somebody so H
yeah maybe they have people giving away
money or something I don't know we've
been given away mark I mean while that's
where the homeless people are there I
don't know I'm saying like people are
donating to him I don't know why that
they're there but yeah there's a park or
- well you can we can still score yeah
yeah it's a park near my house I guess
that's what you'd get like if you wanted
to get you're just kind of a dealer but
that's where all the homeless like
junkies are what do you have here we go
we did know I've gotten it at the other
park near the cellar
really yeah it's Joey you would be so
angry you think there's any sort of
reaction to any bad jokes in the world
you would never stop you wouldn't stop
yelling about it for four months about
how bad the weed was it was like smoking
air there is nothing and they did a
switch on you that I saw but even when -
let me smell till I can't smell this and
I smelled it and then I saw him do the
switch but I'm like hey dude the [__]
you just had me smell also smells like
nothing like I know you're gonna switch
into something worse but like it was
already below the level of I thought
when did in Indonesia I've had weed that
was it was okay it was not as bad as
that but it was slightly worse it was
almost as bad well they don't check it
out of LAX now so yeah they don't check
it take it with you twenty-eight point
five grams is what that's what you're
allowed to take on your luggage 25 does
that an ounce
twenty-eight point five grams a the
twenty-eight point five they even give
you the money that's a high yeah yeah
yeah out to chat we'll have you have to
break it apart like women's breast milk
28.5 put into baggies and put in your
travel kit yeah the edibles if you
fly I mean unless you want to be a
[__] show-off yeah
you take these champion and you put them
on your regular life sorry a part of
your blood pressure every we all have
that package where you take a pill for
you extend away go whatever the [__] it
is you just put one in there so I have
these all mixed in right yeah so you
know you lose the track from though huh
I lose track sometimes sometimes like
you know which ones Belize
what happened was I took the 25 or mange
witson to the hundred Game one delete
and he'll a 225 200 - so now I got
remember the [__] switch see you're
the devil so now I'm at the house and I
have that switch bottle next to me yeah
I got a closet full ATX hundred
milligrams 50s and 25 well I think you
can make those hundreds I mean I could
make him for you I guess no they make
these for everybody these are for
everybody
Josh Pope said he ate two of them one
night yeah he was playing the drive home
in San Diego yeah in that stage he got
like a nervous breakdown he went back
through the room laying over the bed he
goes for ten minutes I'll be all right
and he woke up the next day at 10:00 the
[__] morning with his sneakers on my
heart that's how good these [__]
things are when they first started
coming around it took me a long time to
adjust 100 milligrams I just started
popping - what are you talking about oh
we've been on two 50s and this is
nothing that's why these are so [__]
strong why would you well we first got
alright well we were doing the stars
right we built such a tolerance to that
CHC from the stars they yes we would eat
two thousand milligrams but it really
was the two thousand milligrams any more
for us it was more like a thousand after
surgery that's not quite a lot though
it's
don't minimize that to nothing that's
still quite a lot as [__] well it's a
mere bag of shells you don't know
because I mean he's one of the ones that
didn't come back when it became legal so
like it said 2000 but maybe it was 1500
like these I believe these are I feel
like that's nothing cuz they're never
slightly off it's still so far more than
any other person in the world takes well
yeah
Oh uncle people take what working on
[__] that's right you got your own we
walk to the beat of our own drum itself
we go deep it took me maybe six months
to be able to handle one of these like I
know if I took one of these I'd [__] up
on stage really cuz they're pure THC oh
yeah you take one of these I am [__]
up on stage yeah gonna get a bump but
I'm saying if if I okay but sir
selfishly I'm saying it's if I normally
take twenty of a normal one Ronnie gave
me 200 which is ten times that of the
pure stuff I'm saying isn't that maybe
too much let's take them let's do a
mystery pill some people got the cowbell
I got Altoid can you know I'm saying
there's the mystery wait wait wait what
other one I forgot about that but who
gives a [__]
what are we doing crazy take the pill or
no wait no way I'm coasting for a little
bit take a pill or another but what we
doing it's so black though but we got to
go rough alright what we doing here
let's go get a smoke some weed first and
then we'll get back to fit all right so
do a pill you're gonna wait for that
candy to kick in okay they can yeah I
gotta kick it it's gonna kick out and
what is it speed I mean exercise
give me another piece he needs to go
home and rub his chest on his dick whack
off on his stomach one last time you
whacked off on your stomach today and
just left it there
why table the stone a podcast you gotta
you know [__] oh never come oh I
want you guys to go off the rails again
people were begging me to go what off
the rails to eat a bunch of edibles to
get Lee [__] up so you guys got a
couple minutes to the side of a [__]
pill or a [__] you know somebody gave
me somebody in Maui once got me Maui
Wowi because they listened to our ass
Podcast from a long time ago why don't
you have a TV in here anymore that's
what you need for realize we watched
Adventure Time after last one you
[__] bolted we watched Adventure Time
I never seen anything so [__]
brilliant it was like wow that's illicit
tonight we'll go on with our venture
trip it's even available take your
[__] picture once the smoking
briefing tell you if you could have only
have one drug one more time of your life
go all out I'm just like one line but
like a night of coke or night of
mushrooms or neither ask for like one
obviously it goes with weed which one
would you do if I could still do them
the way I used to do yeah one night with
Zanic some weed with a broad it moves
nice what would you do a valium
like 30 milligram of Valium then you
come one time yeah chicks come easy when
they eat valium is a mix it's either
relaxed I mean what would you like I
don't want I know what chick they would
have to eat them xanax
there come oh really yes any time I gots
a mix that with the one sauce huh but if
you add I'm too old to do cocaine I
don't want that feeling that yeah it
cooks every once in a while it's around
and it's like [__] if there's nothing
else and everybody's doing it I get like
we were talking about a birthday a day
but are you cope is tremendous if you
use it yeah we discussed it Birds I
thought about after we had the
discussion my friend that was doing that
my friend that was doing that as a
multi-millionaire he went to Boston
College I tremendous degree works on
Wall Street and this is 93 when he came
up through the one night things I can
use cocoa communally anything yeah he
goes by me uh 31 gram was dirty back
down the hall in 7 th Street right
already
he would buy a gram I would give it to
him at 9 o'clock at night we bar bounce
now if we go to a couple bounces on the
lower west side by 20th Street 15 Street
down there he knew a couple places
Goodfellas pizza yeah
down there and then had about 11:30
12:00 o'clock he would go to the
bathroom and take two key bumps out of a
grant and give me the rest
Wow and that would take the school to
2:30 yeah and he was gone and never got
addicted never had a pump gel so that he
didn't and he would tie I asked him why
he would do that he would tell me
because it lets me drink a little long
it straightens me up
yeah by the time I get home my dick will
get hard yeah you know sometimes you
write you use it what do you mean you
use it for like what you got to use it
for like we went to a UFC and Edinburgh
in Scotland who starts it like 4:00 a.m.
and it's like and they off coke and it's
like yeah otherwise I'm gonna be dead
asleep
sure let's keep you up for a little
while 3 2 dick Oakland went to the UFC
and watched it know on TV you know and
everybody's going crazy cuz we're all
coked up and it's [__] perfect and
then you know you get some breakfast and
go to sleep
yeah it's great
we watched Diaz and McGregor to to the
hyped up one it was crazy
yeah these guys had [__] fake
McGregor tattoos on Slauson Kuna Cody
are you taking your world tour 2020
overseas in it no no next year I will
yeah for sure yeah next year well for
sure
I saw you release to a dates every
tweedle tonight oh that's them I've only
got a few left I'm doing this show this
[__] Jewish material I'm almost done
and did you find it a synagogue yet
they'll take you not what am I gonna let
me know not one of them not one every
one of them was like some of them were
just like no way like some of them don't
look that good so it's like ah other
ones I'm like they're like yeah sure
we'd love to have that it's not gonna be
blue is it I'm like all right forget it
and then the the one that I really
wanted to do they were like first they
were asking me like no Holocaust jokes
right I'm like yeah for sure you got it
like one [__] [__] about Jews anyway
every one of them was like now we don't
want to do this
so do not get in the backlash bacala no
cuz all it takes these days it's one or
two members of a congregation about well
I don't like this at all
it's the same in any scene NEC there's
not the comedy thing it's any scene if
you have kids in a school anywhere
there's people who like ah what about
John st. ass and it's just like so it's
just easier not to deal with those
people so like schools it would be if
you had a progressive rabbi to be like
that I'd be cool to have in here I get
it I get this is like reverential you
know but like all it takes is like two
people and here the congregation would
be super angry and it's gonna make my
life miserable let me issue this have
you googled like a banded churches yeah
there's one but the fire code is too low
and then and then yeah I could look
across the country but then it's also
got a work like acoustically some of
them are like super echo II you know if
it's you echo a then it's like would you
consider the band in church nah I've
thought about that but it's like that's
not what I'm talking about you know not
just religious parking lot of the of the
temple yeah this is not too but then
I've been I've thought about all this
then it's like it doesn't look like
anything you know or like a Jewish
record center it doesn't look like
anything might as well just do it at a
theater you know so we'll see I'll get
it soon by Boston or New York in the
winter and then dunzo yeah we should I
mean listen no that is the thing that I
applaud you for you know get me at this
point and what's going on I don't want
to shoot a special ever again with the
era nothing right I think all the
theaters have been beat up I think we've
seen everything I mean I understand with
Lisa I almost kicked them buddies in
parking lot but then again not really
right because it today we gotta do
something different you know I know I
think what we gotta do spruce it up you
know there's a hundred percent make it
great from start to finish and that's
the way you stand out mainstream comic
is not gonna stand out it's too it's
it's what everybody watches but it's too
boring nothing you know it's like well
that's way different you know so no one
really talks about it
everybody sees everything now what
happened in Edinburgh where you see five
shows a day for six straight days you
know you see 30 shows and six days
something like that eventually just get
bored so the things that everybody talks
about is the ones that has a big
PowerPoint presentation or a big you
know plant and they audience or
something like that so that's what
everybody talks about but everybody
really likes all the other ones they go
see you know but it's just not doesn't
stand out so a special I think make you
stand out don't just like do something
wacky you gotta do it's got to be like
the best it's gotta be like so funny the
whole way I think and then people go
like wow what I think yeah first was
great it was great got air back you did
yeah I felt bad about what I'm doing I'm
like boy he makes me look at what I'm
doing like a [__] didn't ya sack of [__]
I mean this is brilliant
I mean took him layers he actually
improvised a little bit which a lot of
people don't do which actually liked how
the special yeah if you just you know it
provides a little bit go off book a
little bit little bit show the people
you are human take a chance
yeah take a chance you know yeah I think
his was the best I've seen it was great
it was great yeah [__] funny and he
really showed who he was - yeah that's
like Albert Hall Led Zeppelin played
that it was really pretty I don't
normally like looking at the at the you
know it would be the audience but it was
like yeah the few shots behind it was
like [__] look at this it's nothing
beautiful it was shot be defending my
boy find a great job it is what it is so
now you have to see are you am right
that level is shoot at that Peter I say
you shoot in con and this shows you'd
normally do but a little bit better but
you just did that Chicago Theatre or
whatever it's called Chicago Phoenix
cargo theater damn bro you know I have
that might on my wall still though the
double post-service the the three of us
no me and you the playing card
oh we went to the House of Blues the
blue Chicago then which photo head lies
we were walking out of there Justin our
agent said look down the corner that's
who you and Ari started a couple years
ago
even the Chicago deal it's just tiny
little things 400 seats together 400
seats yeah no one did 600 seats or
something we did two shows well no we
didn't show just as one was yeah st.
Louis is right ones that place I don't
know what that play that we did Buffalo
the kid booked this in Buffalo years ago
eight years ago bride more than I think
showed up you know I saw in st. Louis it
really got me thinking so uh I went on
did 35 whatever was in my time then you
went on and then I was just walking out
the back just looking at how it looked
at you know in the room and so it
they've had a deck outside and you could
go and there was you could see it
through this big bay windows like garage
door windows you know but clear and you
could they were pumping it out so you
could hear it too and I was just
standing behind everybody I heard these
two kids you starting doing some story
there's two kids going
I forgot what story was it was like the
some story but I hadn't heard it before
maybe I had but they were like oh he's
doing the mrs. story and they got all
excited about it and then I was like oh
so then I was like thinking about you
and Bert and stuff like that about Bert
talks about the machinist I can't people
like water like a hit sometimes you know
we had this discussion of Bert's the
other day yeah poor kid was a Molly if
you were [__] up with looking like
tuna you know you reminded me of a
[__] West the guy from Aspen the
writer
oh and that [__] shot is
what's-his-name shot his ashes out of a
cannon hunt the rest of songs didn't
even look like those sure Don but one of
the things we were discussing with
specials yeah
against a storytelling show for me
I know pound for pound nothing helped my
career more
yeah because I see when I get out of
stage and I'm taking pictures there's
always somebody who's got a beef with me
for not saying the story and I'm like
for not saying what oh yeah that was six
years ago
all right we really wanted you to say
that we came here you know for a long
time I was telling you had to gay people
come to my show
yeah oh yeah okay that I even had
lesbian girls coming once with the
[__] with the cornrows and they were
like the guy that was supposed to be the
male the one that was supposed to be the
manly relationship she said we wanted to
hear the Martin the [__] story bro you
know I'm like Larry God you know they
were game they said [__] nobody said
nothin else can so I think it officer
got you when you would do him it was
just a live ones all the time and you're
like you know every like four months you
do on five months you know every five
times we did it it was like can you do a
story with this know like y'all think of
something you know and you're always
like run to it you know really get
something good and it's so weird when
you think of a story when you want to
tell like I love this is what I do love
about getting on stage I love getting on
stage focusing on the handful of jokes
that I think I'm gonna say but then
somewhere along the line I have an
opening and you're going to something I
go into something long I [__] love
that yeah I love that like gesture and
if a Bill Hicks said were you right to
justify what you're telling them you
know writing to I'm telling you this
story
yeah to justify a little about to tell
you so you don't want to shock this is
why I think this way so sometime is
telling them a piece from your life like
when when the senator got accused of
choking that girl 32 years ago well the
guy in the Supreme Court whatever his
name that's fine no Kevin no okay you
have to think about that 32 years ago
when you were a twenty-year-old let's
just say 2021 you between the ages of 21
22 yeah 18 and 22 you covered a girl's
mouth at a party
yeah did he [__] you know he covered
your mouth a guy like me gets really
insulted by that that's just typical
[__] why did you raise your hand for
what is the point of you raising your
hand
did he [__] you in the ass no did he
pull Lewis he can you know so what
you're telling me is he covered your
mouth at a [__] party and you
remembered now 32 years later well right
now while you're laughing at me 32 years
ago I was going on a gay bar to buy
quaaludes and I'd see two gay guys
sticking their fingers up their ass I've
our mentors 32 years ago yeah so I
studied so hard right so when you tell
somebody a story that opened you know I
tell story when I was 12 I had a [__]
friend of my mother's I called an end
yeah one day I went to a house to take a
pee and it was doing that puberty age
when you got a hard-on all the time and
when I went to wash my hands I saw she
had a douche bag hanging yeah with the
hose never miss sniffing the [__]
hose and whack them one off any
microphone ass give me not even have a
magazine oh just just your imagination
just from the older or the douche the
works elects to really walk what you're
not a [__] to get the water in there
yeah you never seen your mother's
hot-water bag what mostly you're too
young I water my mother in America had a
red hot water bag yeah you filled it up
with hot water it's supposed to be for
your neck oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah the red one with the red
yeah but if you look at the bottom
there's a hose okay you could there's
like a little thing things you would
smell that no then you have all like a
little four foot hose yeah and then it
would have something that looked like a
skinny penis yeah with the end of it
having little holes so which sprinkler
you [__] so women would take like
vinegar and whatever the [__] they would
put you know you stick it in your snatch
and let the [__] thing drain out and
then it would kill all the germs and
everything but that stick would smell
like [__] and vinegar well I was 12 I
didn't know opposed I smelt like so I
would smell the stick and just bang one
out of the bathroom all red [__]
my mother will ask me what's going on
with you know like that so are you gonna
judge me for that I did it one time that
was you know saying so let you know
about Cavanaugh covering somebody's
mouth yeah that ain't dick you know and
I told the story about when we lived in
Aspen well there's an aster it was me
Chino and Jimmy Burke oh we did
everything together
Kaena would come over at 8:00 with the
new exotic weed so he would get weed
from Polk County there's a lot of 19
year old kid this guy was already
getting we'd sent to him in a box on
ball counting all different strands
every three days he come in with a
different strand and sell it to us in
fact I would give him money and go if
you find anything
mr. Kenneth Foreman get it for I'm in
the market and I don't like of me him
taking me the Woody Creek tavern
and seeing under his Thompson I don't
have seen him what at the bar just there
in 83 yeah that's why he's called Woody
Creek tavern oh it's okay to oil me down
it so it was Halloween night it was on a
Monday night and I think he was from
somewhere in Minneapolis and my dick
Minnesota was playing we could even look
it up Minnesota was playing or something
so we asked that has a big Halloween
parade
yeah and our big plan was me I'm 19
kayla was 21 then Jimmy's probably 23
and one of us had a plan to dress up
like an abortion so we all got flannel
underway along with the way up in the
eighties remember used to go down to the
ankles then you had the white shirt I
was thick we put that on white we put
like abortion and we put hangers around
our neck
what yeah we were gonna go to a parade
dressed up as abortion so think about it
when you think about that's what
happened
we ate quaaludes yeah we ate quaaludes
and we started drinking we just getting
ready to leave and also next thing you
know I'm getting woken up it's falling
the more like dog we passed out what the
[__] uh-huh thank God we never made it
to Aspen
we felt somebody would have [__]
taken a picture and some people release
yeah of course we wanna hang around like
that which were seeing an abortion on a
[__] party uh-huh you know we all are
allowed to make those mistakes damn by
elects house we had a party once
Halloween party you saw yourself and
somebody came in 2001 Halloween 2001 as
the World Trade Center mid attack so
this was 55 days later 60 days let no
for 50 days later and it was him in this
big world trait thing a plane in it and
then the nose out with an explosion all
coming out it was an amazing amazing
costume but the timing people were angry
like a cult people were very angry yeah
yeah it was great I mean oh my god same
time how would you feel horrible father
had died that night yeah I was sure
horrible I think he got ahead with a
bottle on I think that's the kind of
party it was yeah so for you to wear
that you better be able to back that
[__] you better have a strong head and a
helmet you know the saying cuz usually
get hit across somewhere like you have
to go to a party where people understand
you yeah a bunch of your friends use
kanga a bar in Midtown there's a comics
party that lady was invited randomly
yeah I can't wait I loved it
you walk into New York yeah Halloween
with that outfit oh yeah that'd be
ballsy this is it this is the [__] I
think it is all over Best Coast yeah I
think that the smart thing would just be
to call a cop the cops I don't look up I
can't get out of here just look up like
this is the [__] we trained for
to take these [__] morons no one
listen let's take them on the back I'll
give you each a nickel killing funny
Yankee Stadium with the [__] outfit
on we'll make a statement and you wore
that [__] suit yeah you
that's by the way that's what those
people gel in line get angrier jokes
yeah it's the same thing but we really
hate that we'll do anything don't talk
yeah they said listen there's some
things that they think would didn't
wholesome make a joke about someone
named their original room and then
people walked out yeah all the time so
he said something really [__] up one
time gotta walk some people done do you
see have you guys I saw Stanhope walk in
the room once in the most brilliant way
what'd he do he just want I think the
room set to 20 yeah he probably walked
30 people Wow what's her saying what
just horrible stuff or just let it go or
I'll [__] masterfully yeah it was
1997 and people were just not ready for
Doug's day oh yeah he came up up way
before people relay that's commenting on
[__] and then I'm staying up for his
opening joke not his opening joke one of
his [__] in the middle with the
highlight of his set was when you're
drinking at a bar and somebody comes up
to you and wants to buy so you roses at
a bar oh yeah waka Modi I would come to
you with a bucket of cuts and he was
saying I gotta [__] have you feel the
woman's shoulders if you said I'm had a
woman lady show the girl like my rose
and they could buy a bucket of punch and
then he'd rather take a bucket of [__]
over right there oh you see people slam
the tabs down and then as they were
walking out he would attack them like
please don't go nowhere you haven't even
heard me [__] than done in the ass
routine well that's it
you're an embarrassment to comedy and
the other people would be laughing in
the audience that's one type walking
people I once saw two comments from
Seattle Walker really walk a room
everybody on purpose I mean if there was
80 people 70 gotta really walk a room
walk the room run
Washington is a little island across
from Seattle you have to take a ferry
there yeah it's very gay person it's
very military that's the deepest point
in the United States so that's where
they have all of submarines launch out a
lot of people complain that it's 11c the
Birmingham Washington or well I just say
Wellington Wellington Bremerton
Bremerton Robinson somebody please
correct me well listen for this from it
was a guy up there that was great he had
a little bar he feeds you and I was like
at the time in Seattle he was the comedy
magic show if you took the ferry over
they'd pay for the ferry really he'd
give you ten bucks to take the ferry a
long time Oh used to be every day
[__] it sweetheart of a guy he feeds you
I don't know how many Wednesday's he put
me up me Josh wolf Fridays and then one
day he called and he goes do you want to
be a part of this show what so this
particular show and it was like a dirty
[__] show oh he wanted to do like a
dirty real r-rated shown I said no I
don't know why I said no I just didn't
wanna I don't know and I just it just
wasn't for me yeah the other two comics
weren't for me that was when they made a
pact amongst each other to walk the
[__] room I have you know I'm gonna
walk them because they were like [__]
these people handle things sometimes if
you hates the crowd you're just like no
no no though it was about that something
had happened with a bunch of kids
oh the Oklahoma bombing okay did you she
finally made a joke about you gotta try
it it's so hard to do it like the day
after or two days after but man it goes
south almost every time but sometimes
you hit and it's so good when you can
hit a tragedy joke when everyone's still
feeling it it's the best feeling
but it goes psycho south a lot you have
to be
and you have a tragedy the problem with
a tragedy joke you better have a plan B
and Plan B better be strong for example
Kevin Nealon you know Kevin Nealon I
mean what two or three months after
[__] Bourdain died yeah he had the
most brilliant yeah yeah well he says it
but the b2 that was so strong that they
forgot about it
yeah because three months later I wanted
the day after I want it when you still
feel in it yeah number that you can make
a 9/11 joke now one of the funniest
things ever it was Chris Berg why yeah
was that some game this girl from let's
McCabe writers house to friends of
theirs that we in the world at the time
in this dinner dinner the one gay guy is
Chris Berg was so are you still opening
the Joe Rogan huncles yeah from kind of
the time the other guy goes I can't
stand Joe Rogan he said he called nobody
called the Queen to cut two days after
that she died the Queen of England Libya
when she got hit run off the car
Oh princess died it's his diet oh yeah
gays love princess died called her a
[__] uh-huh all these gay guys in the
audience there was a gay comic from
Boston that was [__] hilarious and he
was a sweetheart of a guy and that's who
they were with oh yeah he brought his
gay friends to watch em dude
okay oh he went up and called that
Princess Diana [__] oh they like hated
it and they [__] he's like he said
that when the guy said cut the other two
gay guys were at the table and I was
[__] hahaha
one of the worst audience members is the
two drunk gay young gay
they are so self-absorbed where they get
too drunk they'll hear they don't
tension and they hear one thing they
don't like and they go yeah and they
make it all about them because they
don't like it not being about them in
life and they just [__] try their
best and you just demean them just go
shut up prissypants we're sorry we're
not gonna be mad like you there's no
reason you're mad just go upstairs
prissy pants sorry they're just angry
they just get so mad they're bad of the
drunks sobered they're [__] great and
one on one they're also great the two
drunk gay is one of the worst audience
members the young Latino too drunk
there's a problem a lot if you do
anything were you shorty bravado then
they're like they feel like they got to
do something like ice house kind of like
you know I'm with a a would talk we had
the only game people okay I never
touched the subject when I was first
starting them that's like I feel like
Tommy storm and the guy who knows how to
work in gang them with the best gay
crowd work oh-ho-ho mr. Andrew really
mr. Andrew Dice Clay takes it so far he
gets up to laugh at themselves yeah and
I've seen him do it I saw him do that an
open mic set on Sunday night he just
destroyed the way yeah and he does that
but what do you do for a living
you own a restaurant don't you you know
like he just was just [__] parade now
he goes what happens when I open up a
fortune cookie at your restaurant what
does this say a [__] suck my dick they
were on boy yeah and then one time I saw
him destroy a table of gay guys just bad
and I was like oh like I was shocked I
thought there was gonna be a stampede
and he just kept cold and gone and ride
them and then he closed with the he
didn't closed the show but he closed the
bit he goes let me tell you something UK
folks he goes pretty soon they're gonna
build the building but casino just for
you [__] and I forget what he says
gonna be called but he goes every 20
minutes it's got a burst and comes gonna
fly on in thought
I don't think and all you [__] gonna
be on the bottom let the sperm hit you
and come on
that's how you deal with gay guys
alright I don't buy too much later
I'm a Miami and I think it's like
Margaret show by lining so I was doomed
oh yeah get out there's no illness and I
just was dying my material was dying
because I was tiptoeing yeah yeah don't
go into it all around it if there's a
table of flamboyant gay men in funny it
don't tiptoe in the front of the room
don't let oh let them run the room yeah
and right away I attacked them and I
told them you're all [__] what'd you
come in a Volkswagen or a Delia's
[__] each other up the ass at the
same time and they were on board yeah
and all my fears about talking gay stuff
went away you know it's like when you go
up and there's four black people in the
audience yeah guess what they want you
to attack what they sent the front for
drug you go I know in this for black
dudes in the second you see them so you
see the ones they don't they wanna get
exact get go for it they want you to
[__] go out look at you for black
[__] to live in handsome okkkk
town you have to address the elephant in
the room
yeah there's white people all around for
[__] black guys in Omaha Nebraska you
have to address that
yeah you have to then so watching Andrew
yeah work a room let me know how to
address things yeah work around and you
know like a dog an audience like a dog
you gotta train it you gotta [__]
punch it in the nose when it's not
acting right you got to reward them when
they're acting well after I saw that
that's the man I made that lesbian come
up to show me a [__] yeah I'll take out
my [__] if you take out your dick and I
took out my deal deal and it was a deal
breaker lesbians like love - yeah I'm
not listen I don't I don't even from
life when that walking habit
yeah why not what that walking and
Seattle happened it was 96 no I was
doing five year was I was a comic
five years at the five-year mark I was
stupid I was a loser I was addicted to
coke but I knew that walking people Oh
welcome to God okay I wasn't why I got
this business no you don't want to try
but sometimes you got to do it take that
money okay so I remember when we went to
La Jolla once me you and Kelly Kirsten
you remember that yes okay hold on I
went on first and that Kelly Kirsten wet
and I guess these people bought tickets
for the wrong show they bought tickets
for yeah for the main room of the comedy
store where it was more clean started
tonight our show starts at 8:00 and
10:00 or 8:00 and 10:30 whatever but
they sat through me and they were like
well this is way too dirty that's when I
was really dirty too they sat through me
and they took it like art maybe just the
opener and then Kelly went on and she's
[__] filthy sure right now I think
and she's filthy and then these two old
people this couple they come out and
they're like listen this is what what is
this this is not we signed up for this
is dirty you said it'd be clean and
they're like we never started be cleaned
where did you call this here the 9
o'clock shows like that's LA you call
the LA Comedy Store no we didn't it's
like well we don't have a 9 o'clock show
and they do when it's a clean comedy
show and they kept talking and we were
sitting down by with a the end of the
bars with the stained glasses there and
you just got up and you were headlining
but that's when they didn't come for
anybody never just been there the
longest right now and Kelly second
longer then I was a newest it was just
like they just send you down together so
you hadn't been on yet and you get up
and you go over you like get the [__]
out of here get the [__] out if you're
not gonna take a beat it get the [__]
out and you scream it on all the way
into the [__] sidewalk yeah you had
up to here you're listening to them
listening to them complain complain
complain and then you're like get just
get the [__] like they're not customers
anymore you know you're just complaining
on your way out [__] beat it oh it's
so great to see let me know like I'm so
sorry mister missus that comes
many times I've seen people just get up
and walk up they turn around wait just
let me get my dad that's okay they walk
out I'm fine that's cool it's not for me
I don't like Nate a favor just leave I
forgot to make a phone call whatever
it's okay don't don't stop at the desk
girl on the desk person and break their
[__] balls
yeah you didn't like it what do you want
you want you to only 250 back yeah or
you stopped at the door yes I'm on your
way up again you getting coward you
can't see them I mean this is gone I
Love New York City yeah I love
everything about New York City was where
I was raised if you watched my walk it's
my walk that's my talk you can tell by
the way he wasn't I [__] read that
they had to put up a sign from louis c.k
come with the comments that way it's not
real I real think they're supposed to be
mad about something it's not real I came
from a society you don't waver let's go
yeah oh I did actually me and my
girlfriend Kate let's come you went to
see a comedy show at the comedy factory
outlet in Baltimore this guy was like
there were dishes like racists in the
crowd they just kept yelling this black
dude headliner and he kept like dealing
with it and they just kept like it was
just kind of awkward I don't know how
much they intended or whatever but it's
like you know Baltimore's like on the
edge of like redneck and City and it was
just like weird and then she was like
let's just go and I was like yeah all
right and then we're like hey man it's
not you bringing out here this is
[__] weird and he was like yeah he
was cool about the comic but I remember
doing that just like you know we're just
gonna leave like it wasn't like a thing
you know I can't imagine like this
movie's boring I'm gonna go but soon as
that just sucks they just go just go
just right you got a bad movie murder
she's Godfather yeah I can name 10
situations he had the same tolerance I
had really the reason why him and I got
a long shot at all friends after 40
years is because I don't know how many
times we were somewhere six minutes and
then and we just look at each other do
me my girlf went to a shitty movie the
other day we're both kept looking
but nobody can make the call to be like
you want to go right either want to
share enough to ask we just get a look
at every after we were like I thought I
wanted to go I thought I wanted to go no
yeah I never understood go look at today
it's your time today we live with you -
yeah so it takes you 2 minutes to look
up the comic and say I don't want to go
see it it's not like the old days I'll
tell you who used to get a lot of slack
who Mooney work it out know who our
brother wrote him get a lot of flack for
what when he was on Newsradio yeah
people would go see him and you could
ask him tomorrow yeah I'm gonna being an
animal you can ask him I think one of
every five shows some [__] body would
scream out what no no no no no not even
scream at what I'm talking annex he
would [__] in somebody would come up to
him and the worst place ever was in
Miami sometimes known what it would be
like three white chicks
oh the whites exhales I'm a white couple
and they go excuse me really I was right
there I witnessed them saying we really
were not happy to your performance we
came to see Joe from Newsradio
that we came to hear all this abuse and
women and they're all mad he would
[__] launch that's what he did smoke
pot and it was [__] he didn't give a
[__] get in that girl's bra you know
it's a Comedy Store guy here that's Ross
he would [__] say and I remember
there's one girl one day said horrible
things to him and Joe took it it was me
Chris Maguire and Joe I'll never forget
this yeah and this [__] just wouldn't
stop and joke like if I had any time I
read a little NBC this is a forceful
trail and he's like I'm a [__]
fiction Webber I'm what character yeah
I'm a fake [__] character of a TV
show lady she said someone [__] damn and
he's like you know what were you a
victim at dodgeball
he just walked out of there like she
just ran out that's a third group drunk
white chicks right there the one area
that they're worse there
so bad that's the third group there you
can't even deal with them there's no you
annoying so just know right now at this
point in your career yeah
are you still having phones it shows
that people walk out I don't think so
but I like to hear about I hear about
once in a while it's not a problem
and they're never like yelling he's
usually religious people for this hour
it's a religious people when it's just
like you know they came for the for the
Saturday night and there's just like
it's just too much you know does it
bother you know if 20 people walk down
and be a show I would find it
interesting but I really think like if
you walk the line you want to walk the
line right the line is fun you like what
that means some people the line is not a
straight line it's more like waves so
some people have to be over that line
otherwise you're not at the line yet you
know that when people walk out I mean
Eleanor we're talking about this if
people walked out in Vegas like but you
need that because if you want everywhere
else to be like oh like one of those
laughs it's only that laugh because you
know some people go over that now
that's not cool you know you need those
people walk it out to make everyone else
really enjoy it because it's like a line
Walker joke is it one specific joke oh
it's just that type of humor no I'm
saying it when they walk out of your
shows oh is it well no I don't think so
I think i think this if it's this year
it's just because it's like too dirty or
like they just really don't know what
they're getting into but right but
they're adults about it mostly there's
like oh it's not for me about three
years ago
too much [__] on God though I
decided it's not what I signed up five
years ago suddenly ran out of a show
mine Lexington and they were like [__]
you he's mad why that was that time and
then in st. Louis had a bunch people
walk out but because the [__] pipes
every time somebody flushed the toilet
and there's no like [__] in the club and
I'm seeing these people walk out of my
heart breaking yeah you know listen I'm
trying to run a business here yeah I'm
not trying to serve shitty hamburgers I
understand that we live in a world we
all can't wait for the light right yeah
but in today's world with all everything
we have available to us
I yelled Italy two years ago for going
to see bad sad I'll see if I go what's
that Santa
that sensor - uh-oh you couldn't tell it
was gonna be bad just by the trailer -
is never good just the 20 doesn't know -
that's ever good like a towel a movie
now from the trailer yeah for sure you
could and 90% of your 30 year old and
you can't tell from the trailer if this
movie's gonna suck yeah and you can
almost tell from the Billboard cuz you
can tell from the top where there's you
know I could tell from a trailer our
trailers cut yeah
about what time movie it's gonna be if
these are the highlights right for that
movie and I'm gonna tell you what movie
start the most what what this one what's
time what well I did the movie with De
Niro is still old it was a box it was
red yeah the trailer yeah let you know
that that was the movie me I'm gonna
scene with him Gavin hard argue with the
trailer let you know this is how honest
I am you know how about how annoying is
it when you know I did it one movie and
it was so bad how annoying is it when
you know you just did a bad movie first
off it's just that you don't know it's
gonna be a bad movie - you're shooting
it Yeah right til you're there if their
experience is bad the Energy's bad
that's gonna come across on the phone
yeah I did 20 of those but I knew what I
was getting into their 100 oliday movies
right you know those movies that you've
learned how to act then gonna come in it
but you just shoot him to get the 700
hours for the seven days and all the
time and whatever I think what first
time I saw a longer shot I was not very
happy really because it wasn't that
comedy comedy
he was more like action Colin I saw him
stick this finger in his mouth and pull
in the reps here I almost cried you're
like no I'm not part of that type of
humor oh no yeah you're like what am I
gonna do can I do get the hot sweats and
like [__] sit down oh my god I don't
know why is that the second one that
wasn't good I remember you doing that
that was a big thing for us young Colin
yeah like what because that lets say
that lists everybody else
yeah you know it was two days with the
narrow it wasn't everything was not the
opening that was deceptive well yeah the
opening the opening scene yeah the
opening you see yeah right out the back
boom there's no idea who [__] years
all I got was one day one scene two
lines one day one scene two lines and
then I started booking two days couple
scenes but you're always in the opening
has a trailer
I booked three movies with credits right
hahaha
you know like it was a [__] nightmare
you got two days but credits ran through
yeah you're never gonna get the result
that you want and then I got robbed the
Rodney movie and that was like eleven
days but oh yeah Harry basil the one of
the worst movies ever put on tape like
even the table sorry the camera kept
turning off shooting it it's so
everybody was in it everybody everybody
all-star cast for the time yeah I mean
the whole Tommy la comedy scene yeah
yeah
Plus Harlan was right that's what I mean
I like the high level good guy from the
Chevy Chase movies there's no one that
escaped into Canada they were looking
for me [__] that claim where the Quaid
oh yeah a fat chick the chick from
cheese that was the bartender that ate
all the Carla no she ate all the cakes
and [__] Christie Christie I was just
the le oh yeah that's the allergy and
being out of college and her had a great
scene when whacking off and she's
watching me and I'm watching her and I
got a whack off I mean it was a fun
movie to shoot but when I left there
yeah I did not think I was in the won an
Oscar for my but you know right right
right I've always known you know you
always have a [__] idea this the
final movie I can't even tell you is I
don't know what do you know really I
don't know what do you mean the day to
really the shoe we weren't allowed to be
there you know how many days we were on
that thing eight Wow how fun was that
for that's your [__] thing do you
know I've been thinking about like this
year
yeah yeah I just got paid for somebody
did in January by the way yeah so did he
in February I'm a check check
that's hysterical congratulations you
finally pay your car payment monster
came here one day ha ha ha hit it and
then a week later pump my wife I still
haven't paid them I don't know what
happened for the check and there it is
she's gonna die in the morning I gotta
buy honey check like that ha ha ha mommy
guys my wife will give me a check with a
feature act on the road really I will
put it in my wallet and then get to the
airport go to give it some and the check
is gonna and then I just found it you
pay the feature check out of your own
check you don't just have a club or the
place to pay them sometimes I give them
both oh right ok a club yeah they fight
for their [__] lies whatever that
will be giving it up the Glenn bow they
gonna get 50 [__] bomb I'm saying
check what's a check what's red bow then
moves away you can just do that without
writing made out of my wife isn't it
counted everything that's you know
[__] bad mom I mean I remember one
that I went to do a gig you don't be dog
you know how I am about my money at a
comedy show yeah Sunday night shows I
don't know what promoter was he just I
mean so sent me an email
don't I get down then at the end the two
white kids are ok ha ha ha ha ha ha
all I know is everybody gives you an
envelope with yard sticks but I get it
and they were like hold on Wigan it's on
the way whoa because they were like
we'll just sell it to your venmo and
you're like no that's not gonna work
with Joey Diaz no no no we're trying to
swish it out at the standout to venmo
straight till you get the money in your
account you can use a credit I don't
want yeah but sometimes you like the
cash more you should give you $15 a
night and then people would rob the box
right so they stop they give you a check
oh they used to give you the money yeah
I like the money in your hand yeah it's
so nice of the Improv in your hand oh my
god when I first moved to the improv
we'll put the checks right by the door
so you can walk in and go to your harm
when I get my checks they should go go
ahead and you just go through the checks
yeah I can't tell you how many comics
checks I stole how do you steal their
checks because they're right there no
but I mean how do you cash them sign
name putting your Wow and you spit into
your account
I would strain into your account like I
would sign names oh I knew work on a
hassle right right right
I'm not gonna steal Lee's check right no
he's he dueled out of it he's asking
about it right but you know Ron white
he's not coming in first job yeah
there were guys that had stacks of check
you see it like in the water you know
what I was really mad at Bobby Lee I
would go in there I couldn't steal his
checks but I went in there and I just
tore them up and I threw them away so he
wouldn't get them just to punish him I
would go and tear his checks out
hundreds of dollars not like he'll never
get it I went down it woman yeah all
those men see who was at this board Paul
Mooney ripped up his check in his face
lift up come and see us jack you would
do my jokes
this is mama ha ha ha that's lies Eddie
turn Mario into nah resent hood into
Mario I do the same joke I feel great
you ready for another edible no it's not
go heavy are you doing that I'll do an
ADD ok
by the time you get back we'll be ready
to go this break is brought to you by CB
d line calm CBD line is the best CBD out
there how do I know because I tried it
first and then I reached out to them and
asked if I would be interested in them
you know maybe sponsoring the podcast
that's how it started I did the tension
right they put me on a different [__]
level and then they sent me the gummies
they sent me the vapor pads they sent me
the chatter I tried everything except
the shadow you guys know I don't smoke
either I'll tell you what I was [__]
impressed the good thing about CBD line
is listening they're not like this gas
station CBD Shea you see everywhere if
you live in California it's all over the
[__] place
they got CBDs stores I don't even know
what this song with CBD line you go to
their web page and you read the third
party at lab results it's right there
and funny they do everything themselves
from start to finish that's a real
company they care about you listen I
live on detention when I go home down
tonight I'll pop to [__] 5,000
milligrams under my tongue i watch sons
of anarchy and by 12:00 11:45 I can't
even keep my eyes open the most
important thing is I stay asleep all
night so the other problem with sleep
and anxiety CBD line is for you let us
see we didn't I'm not calm right now the
website look at picture anything shadow
if I was you I get the raspberry gummies
the orange gummy is the strawberry
gummies that's the way to go
I love the gummies me I live by the
tension but if you want the gummies
that's a way to go go to cbn.com impress
in church and get 20% off delivered
right the house all right go to see the
BD no Hank calm tell him uncle Joey sent
you how is your fear sit down come so
they have a lot of though take a water
right from that away to dehydrate what
do you feel like you're feeling good
sure oh yeah
no thank you how many points would that
put us a little bit man the acid yeah
what that to somebody gave you a quarter
piece of acid I meant to bring it in
today so he can hit a street Chicago
really in a little form I had two more
than envelope and I knew where the one
was the ones in my bag but the two I had
one that I gave to Lee I just found them
the other day
hey I said I'll save them for today and
they're like a vinyl I know you're a
handyman alright I think I have a
project for you that you'd like it's
easy to prove your life it's a drug box
and you just make a regular box but you
put some like levels in it and you're
right before you put the levels in it
like the separators you write DMT
you're right MDMA you know acid and then
when when you have the drugs you just
put it right there in the box and a
little area marked you know DMT and then
later when you're like where was that oh
it's right there you don't have to know
seen two of them because it's already in
the area do you see what I'm saying
the box I think it's time I think the
asset and I only have one hit so you got
a chaplain let's chop it up into three
now yes what do you want pills oh well I
will do you like we did it we did it oh
he's down no I gave me the 200
milligrams part of the opiate crisis
Jesse Chappelle's bill about the opiates
the bit about the oh yeah who gives a
[__] I'm living it in I'm telling you
you want to be part of the opiate crisis
in that buddy let's do one more
what the [__] it's a holiday that one
lasts how long this which one last maybe
I'll give you a half this is mystery box
and he's going deep see you got a
closely a different way please do not do
do do just slow down on the edibles I a
little bit you did down a little bit I
still take them when I fly yeah I still
take them on the road there funniest
response to ever had with you as you
reading with one of the he's a day I
think a auntie Dolores cookie a day and
you're like yeah I had to stop and it
was like why I was like too much too
much weed you're like no the calories
the calories another cookie seven
cookies a week I was getting fat [__]
banana bread that banana bread was you
know - it was thick and rich what we
doing like what are you pressing buttons
for he's the [__] thing what are you
doing there you go it's all over but the
shop
you still having a good time doing
family yeah you still haven't loved it
living in New York yeah it's also really
[__] fun and cool it is oh do you
find cool bars and like there's just
[__] to do
it's great it's great Jesus out among
people I don't know man because this bar
we went to they play a everyone picks a
song they have a bunch of like [__]
vinyl albums and then everyone picks a
song from their list of vinyl albums
they have and then the rate the DJ plays
those songs only one after another while
you eat this like really great meal New
York yeah it's just wonderful and then
your song comes on like 20 minutes like
I said well I chose barrack yeah yeah
it's great
yeah there's like it's just so much fun
with Warlow with the storytelling show
we bring them back who knows maybe
someday be nice huh I started to send it
out there right away it's all one
[__] recently I don't want yeah I
know you do really yeah
I'm trying to put this one-man show
together Ari so I thought I could I'm
like oh I can fit it all in one night I
was I ain't a [__] can I make a
mistake you know I'm gonna break it up
into sections and do all four sections
we tape the first one for me and I
picked out some gems and I got rid of
some others [__] that could just the
same time let me tell you something I
don't see this one-man show being in the
two hours you know I think we should do
now for a while what I want to do is
just like do a bunch of material have
fun and then like tour again listen at
the same places that you know a year
later but with like new material but not
like special just like new material and
then eventually you get this like a
bunch of great material yeah then you're
like boom boom boom boom and then it's
like that's how to do crushing our chasm
that has the [__] recipe trees three
years one year in clubs one year and
theater then you tape the [__] thing
mm-hmm you're patient you know you go
naturally right and on top of that
finally I do 18 months in between the
cities to make sure they come out me too
right yeah tako theater dude yeah
there's no reason to [__] go you know
I saw the weigh-ins there I bet you did
the weigh-ins when you because they
couldn't get the stadium for both the
first night and the second night so they
couldn't do the weigh-ins at this
they were doing the United Center so
they did the way way into the UFC I mean
that was before joke could play it we
both looked at it but like this would be
cooled one day to do but he wasn't even
like foul he did it like a couple 1000
seaters and that was like I was way
bigger now that you do with a little
Esther I to him no not on his Duncan
yeah maybe
was me you made Duncan and that was in
Chicago Thea yeah I remember we're like
wow you did that one thing at the UFC n
that's pretty cool and you did that now
by yourself yes what do you I'm going to
do that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
that was two days ago now we got to do
something no that's why I don't worry
about the public or whatever where
people like can you believe this wasn't
happening it's like everything's going
better than ever
listen here are there some people catch
a cold real bad
you get like hard walk outs of the whole
like everybody getting mad you online
you know I mean but it's like at socks
we get there one time my favorite
audience member ever
is it the Comedy Store the main room
where it's mic a little more clean than
I am or you are you know but you're not
because that's what we thought yeah
that's what really as long as you go in
there with that little [__] look they
they [__] suck it up now I wish to be
hate that [__] main room because I
always thought I had to play a certain
tone tonight main room ever since I
threw that tone out the window I become
a way better comp yeah I would do it
once I got some like I'll do this like
the or actually we're I'm gonna do some
crowd work a little bit first and then
get into it you know instead of this
presentational whatever what the scary
thing is that you as a young comic when
you got into the store you looked at the
main home as this distant thing just
like you couldn't like what like you
look at it there's all the heavy hitters
were there so it's like I guess I gotta
put on a show she'd always make you
[__] follow somebody who was gonna
torch it he's high all the hell you had
a follow no but no but I can imagine
following that he think before I got in
there oh my god tell me about Heath
Heath I had characters he had cutouts it
was the biggest [__] show and you
crush oh my god he had a [__] gospel
band behind
he would just go come out come back that
that [__] japanese-american fight in
the plains he would crush so hard turn
around come back with some [__]
massacre it was like half carrot top
half like [__] Iron Maiden they level
a [__] runaround he had you know I li
when he was arms with with the
Tabernacle Choir yeah that's happening
where Mohana they were they were all
like [__] statues okay so he didn't
travel a little quieter no he dropped
them on it oh you couldn't help it man
he killed you he doubled you over it's a
Vegas show that would work in LA yes
that's how good it was
with the original room it would stop in
the main room the bay room he couldn't
really have the room in the original
room I saw him try a couple of times he
killed in there too but no it's easier
for the man because he had the space
behind the stage but a Vegas style act
shouldn't work in LA and he was so
[__] strong that it was like now
people they were like this is [__]
great but it's a Vegas style comedy act
that worked in this [__] Cydia but he
always went out early so thank you that
[__] you know he's going up a
like 9:45 I was really I guess a little
close with him now at 2:00 in the
morning why would you close family
he's [__] does this big magical clean
I mean he wasn't that the way part of
the half was for the in mix yeah yeah
did you didn't really have much choice
it was where it was [__] Mitchie sure
you didn't have a choice it was [__]
sure but she sure put him on cuz he was
such a big act he was going on the road
that I remember his mane was Alabama the
Birmingham and that was the biggest room
the country yeah at the time in the late
nineties that seat like 4:30 I don't
know if you've ever been there that's a
big [__] room so that was one of his
big things sweetheart of a guy he nights
yeah sweetheart of a guy yeah just
basketball I think he's on ships now
well he disappeared from the store I
already know what happened him he may be
moved maybe got married to Pasadena
wants but yeah I always assumed he was
like doing massive theater I don't know
is he not he should have you know I
don't know what happened to him when he
killed there was some oh my god when I
was like a ham and Sanchez him Sanchez
there was three or four you know you how
she's to kill who Luke Torres the Torres
would kill in the middle area
Torres got a standing ovation one night
the original anybody I tell you all
shoot to kill the original in those days
Pierre back here black Pierre
yeah there was a lot of guys at the
store in those days too
it just wasn't the place to be right now
we weren't getting Cyrus oh man Lewis CK
wouldn't go in there no you know bill
burr was in New York by that time nobody
was really over there
okay Rogan was going in there but see it
was going in there during the weekend
bumping my Lawrence was gone
Tyson Griffin Griffin yeah a big [__]
torture chain yeah and you'd have to sit
there all night way for any girl for the
common wall if you wait in line wait in
line waiting lying that Eddie Griffin
she was upset well it's good to put team
one in six hours once Eddie Griffin
showed up Ferg a like me it was Miller
time [__] give me the money
get out no there was no money what for
[__] I was gonna give you money there's
no money you got $15 yeah if you didn't
go up mitts you didn't give me the 50
that's [__] workers rights that's
[__] at the Congress L don't give
you money
Chappelle goes on and goes and does
[__] whatever they'll be like you can
get paid which they sure have to do the
times filled anyway the time that you
would have done is filled so give me
that money no it's already we don't like
it we don't got to go up give me the
money at least some of that Tuesday
nights because of the guy Torry show
yeah it was so intimidating that nobody
white will go there on twos in the whole
building
yeah the word got out that listen you're
overpowered and then it's gonna that's
when the manager got held at gunpoint
and who Eddie Griffin had to talk
down ya know it was a scary point there
but Tuesday nights guys like me I need
that $15 yeah it's a that's a big amount
of dirty doubt I gotta get it and you
would stay by the Union you would do
Felipe's room but yeah night you have to
keep calling the Comedy Store on
Tuesdays and they go we have four people
come on down and you'd pray that to more
people walked in yeah you know many
times I pulled in you gotta they'd had a
move all right come on in guys no you
had a [__] go into the original room
pull out of the parking lot every black
people everywhere this guy stories night
and then you had a walk and they Taylor
show just got canceled
oh because they could never call you by
the way the show's canceled they people
are still on the line up an hour from
that mi you can at least call the never
left channel it would boy they would
never call thirty minute nobody cared
but those time listen if you have a
spotter nobody cared they never called
you you got a spot at one o'clock yeah
you're there at 11:30 right well also
you gonna do what do you know what
that's true I'll let you got a spot
that's true
if you got a spot I grow a lot of laughs
you do already did a spot and you at the
store at 11:30 going on your friends
yeah really go see you get a joint yeah
[__] have a drink but this guy always
in town so you knew already
you knew yeah you know damn it's a
different place that's a different
[__] play you miss it when you go to
New York I miss the idea of it though I
mean it's a little it's it's a little
different right now I still like it
though what are you there the more like
yeah I'll be there tomorrow night I like
hanging out there it's just like it's a
little too popular so it's lost some of
that vibe if I could just hang out and
chill out
should I have a talk with somebody you
can interrupt 25 times just like this
you get everything up today they're
waiting on is crazy
that whether you want order every time
we start a conversation get ready to get
interrupted by somebody with a [__]
question and it's not even the people
come to the show them I can't it's a
comic comics a lot I talked to Rogen one
day about something we just gotta
I'll [__] a female convict I just tell
you how I feel about you just hi would
you do that I don't and there you know
why didn't you help me that hours they
sure didn't he will excuse us hahahaha
she wanted to do is see if you get on
the podcast and he immediately [__]
turn this head and we walked away and
she just ruined this conversation we're
talking about comedy or something it was
getting good - were talking about
specials and some [__] you can't have a
[__] conversation down there unless
you and even in the back if you go back
there I'm one of the big popular shows
there's 80 people back there across the
globe nobody knows had a [__] ass in
the world I don't know if nobody else
how to act
there's a [__] universal rule if
you're not going on stage get the [__]
out agree oh yeah oh that's my Haven so
what I got to do when I do the main room
somebody should go in there and punish
them no you're not in this place you're
not have regular lamp by amplify
outbound you can't you know be the judge
or whatever if you don't like regular or
not you know what I pay regular or not
my buddy was somebody you know what I do
I get it yeah so I sit by the piano
no I sit down with still a ghost yeah
that's not a comic-con stage and I go
[__] who's better than me I'm at the
calm hell well he got this weekend Texas
where San Antone Dallas where Houston
and Antonio lol oh wow
yeah night one night that you go to
where addison one night oh [__] they all
right yeah I like doing this to [__] in
cowboy towns okay and then Houston for
two nights
Friday inside of the improv firing
Saturday then me and Roger conquest this
is the guy who's opening for me they're
both cowboy fans both going driving back
from Houston to Dallas for a very first
Dallas Cowboy game at Texas Stadium
you've been able I've never been there
never even took the tour one or two all
this time couldn't afford to stay next
day for a while and then like you know
we're doing it it lined up with what I
was doing you got a nice ticket no I do
not have ticket yet I still gotta
[__] take they're expensive his [__]
yeah oh [__] damn welcome to [__]
they have a hundred ninety-eight
thousand seats you know if you have a
couple $20 ones though hums pipe dream
well it's gonna bring a break-even week
for me yeah oh I can't wait to go to
these Yankee games you know it's the
Yankees here this year who do you claim
baseball Friday who do you claim
baseball claim nobody I got no [__]
time to play games
oh you're joke whereas her head says
minus seven yeah I know what the [__]
you talking about I know the Yankees are
playing Friday the series starts hey
York [__] I do not want to be in New
York doing comedy it's gonna be crazy
Friday night Friday sadly did I can't
wait those Yankee games are so [__]
fun of the playoffs you go alright go
every time I can every time I would
sound ricketts there whatever they are
they were never there whoever they got a
big one yeah I gotta go sometimes 75
sometimes like 350 you got to do it
whatever they're in the playoffs and
that's your team and you're at home and
you have enough money to spend on the
tickets for the first time in your life
will you take will you take the girl
whoever no I was good she's a days fan I
was gonna take her is the one last year
but they were screaming at anybody with
green I'm glad I did not
whoa speaking of green who's ready for
an animal what are we doing
I know are you gonna stay at that Museum
it's right now you got to [__] you
got to what time what time is it
show me the real time you got a 10:28
you got an hour after you pump your
brakes
there you go eat that [__] day I
don't worry button then we'll give you
something to calm you down - I guess I'm
free to go
sleep with you but nobody'll bother in
the ubirr [__] yeah you fall asleep I'll
lift you wake up with a dick up your ass
and you can't press charges you turn the
camera off
he's got a [__] tolerance he looks
like a [__] nothing he looks like a
[__] Japanese rendition of a thing we
believe you will go there
it's Tuesday lanes Monday night either
you wanna you know if that [__] can't
swim she's bad with trees and you want
to really make it happen yeah take a
needle pop and drink the juice that's
right there at the airport really I
- why why question I gotta believe this
one of them fell out on my pocket so I
put have your phones
yeah and having a phone case so I put
the capsule via phone case and there's I
got a plane from Chicago on Saturday I
opened up to take the earphones and the
thing was starting to leak the earphones
pierced it so I wanted I wanted to leak
all over the bag I took the pill I took
my pillow you guys fly back together
yeah that's 90 Justin okay that's nice a
deed that's like Austin wasn't wrote - I
was in a suite with him but you don't
want to sit next to your friends out of
play at night he won't shut the [__] up
you wonder I know he wants to sleep so I
woke up bro I woke up when the lady was
asking what do you want for breakfast I
said what do you got she said some
cheddar cheese ah me uh forget it give
me the oatmeal you take the open
American and when did you take your life
and do you think you like the Chinese
gonna admit that Bruce Lee will ha does
America down a hill it wasn't bad I have
they give you a little cup of fruit I
don't touch the Greek yogurt I don't
like Greek yogurt the regular Maluku
yogurt don't know it'll give you that I
didn't touch the bun but I was so high I
thought edible but I woke up on the ipod
and played through what I mean like I
fell asleep my ipod on and it had played
every so every song was gone
yeah the Beatles I read it what are you
funny when you just run that one system
that's called like random shuffle yeah
shuffle yeah oh my god all the way
through it you have no idea I'm like I
slide and I remember sitting down and
putting my glasses on eating that
attaboy yeah I don't even date the plane
hi is the best hi Caitlin and you wake
up and you're there
and it's just like you're like what wait
where am I what's happening at was
stopped yeah they're all in the aisle
and like white and I'm thinking should I
get up to go to the bucked up to get up
and say right here so I just do my legs
like this I do my left calf right ah
because the calf muscle is the is the
heart of the leg you want to keep your
blood I was she said that we were
delayed because she could she didn't
know that Joey I don't know what she
does we said the thing for 45 minutes I
just remember waking up the lady asked
me what I want for breakfast yeah
passing out again at a per minute thing
me waking up a give me breakfast being
higher than [__] yeah I don't know what
was playing I think it was uh down in
the hall with playing happy old meal I
[__] ate the fruit yeah I like
looking out the window right then it's
no I think the Alsea oh you do yeah dude
I do another like an adult now I thought
can snack up before I get multiple
different nuts multiple sweets maybe in
an orange if I feel like eating some
healthy and then [__] straight candy
I'm ready any time I wake up I got snack
food ready to go I just ready to [__]
crush a protein bar protein bar that's
what brings antics have to bring the
service cat what's the service cat I got
a service can you bring super out on the
road with you so you can get the better
seats I've had it yeah born 74 I got
second people bleep dogs if you could
travel with yoga bring in the stairs
annex of the cat what do you think I'd
be sorry I need to bring an animal nomad
I'd be like now come on I'm alert
I got halfway oh my god I gotta take
this then we'll wrap it up what you know
get a dog a friend of mine called me his
father said he'd call the whole thing
because I'm gonna say these pills they
they help get out the black rhino hard
study then when he sent them
it's just high-powered garlic yeah and
three or four hours after you eat these
things yeah your [__] does not fart
it has explosions explosions that you
actually go off the chair a little bit
like an ancient - yeah like that louder
than your thing so I hate about four of
my Thomas plane and I said that said she
took the inside window I love everybody
but this [__] was the most annoying
lesbian him she's one of those white
chicks that would complain an economy
show yeah she had to call her talking
loud and then always I faced her and you
know she was just annoying
yeah and then to make things worse she
took that like a paper I started reading
a [__] paper it's just like plenty
people don't like me you're the only one
making a problem she took her shoes off
and it's our feet Oh smaller feet
garbage people but by the looks of her I
could tell you what a [__] smell like
it's not like Newark and I said [__]
this I'm putting this [__] in a
different orbit
I started farting and I could see her
after the third fart she would wave the
newspaper but like to get air inside
between oh I was finite hahahaha with
this one leg up so it was ricocheting
off the back of my calf yeah go straight
in our direction yeah I Drive to the
third or fourth one bro she fell asleep
take as a bucket
he'd take a bag of weed and put it in
his crotch and then we were on the air
line like we're in the air we'd take it
out when you're sleeping and put the
whole [__] like a baggie that big if
illegal we'd put it under your nose what
the [__] are you doing
it's so fragrant sometimes I would take
the bag and spit it around the air oh my
god
it was crazy yeah nice people everybody
like you know I know where is coming
from yeah no [__] they lose the secret
on the subway where you get a bunch of
weed you gotta take it back and you reek
of weed you go stand by a black dude and
then everyone just assumes it's the
black dude who's got the weed I don't
know what you think all this [__] up
yourself you're a regular [__]
refined still yeah you know what you
figure it out
I'm uh assessees and motherhood
adventured I took Thursday night where
are you
San Antonio okay Dallas oh yeah
Chicago's yeah
two shows warshowsky doing chick shows
all together yeah you're [__]
beautiful but yeah back out there
yeah [__] these [__] yeah my last
time with tonight's your last hurrah we
did 300 milligrams of afx [__]
minerals we did to two truths and then
another we've done a couple bong hits
yeah and now we'll take a little to go
what's it go where are we going I don't
understand we just took a hell of drugs
where we going would still eat edibles
apiece
we'd be rather than 500 grams of freedom
you wake up tomorrow you look out the
window they gonna do tomorrow cuz if you
get up his THC juice you smoke at 11:00
you go [__] Lee I won't see him tomorrow
so [__] it'll be and he's ahead by
Sun anyway so well he's like Jewish
vampire you don't see another Sun at all
so Thursday oh wow
Friday Addison no thursday lol Friday
Addison Wednesday lol fried out of self
no Wednesday Thursday a decision Friday
Saturday Houston improv but if you're
not there I got a special on Netflix
it's called double negative and watch
that and then you know because the next
thing I'm doing so what you plan for you
will give me your prediction for so long
Koba okay who's gonna win I'm gonna win
because I am the only one who has a real
life
and who would not get in serious trouble
with their wife so what do you mean
highly in trouble you ain't been getting
healthy and stop doing drunk it's very
annoying whatever you have to do is very
annoying yeah well it's no fun it's no
fun when I have a glass of wine within
it you have to work out also there's
some blessings we're doing what kind of
lessons all sorts of lessons like what
plan is whatever [__] lessons you got
to do jujitsu or [__] Tae Bo or
anything you got to do with ten of them
I hate this [__] so much for the whole
month for the whole month yeah that's a
piece of cake yeah it's just annoying to
have to learn so what are you choosing
I'll probably do a jiu-jitsu class I'll
probably do a couple like spin classes
or something maybe uh maybe I'm like a
language class maybe a couple Spanish
classes
yeah exercise yeah class I don't know
[__] class it's gotta be X why why
does it have to be XS you know [__]
why can't you work on yourself as a
human being you know Joe I do they
Revere the [__] body when it's the
mind that we all know we should Revere
cuz Joe Mahfouz wants it to be a muscles
me understands you know you gotta pay
into this is you're gonna reap in your
[__] mental health is roping you
should
everybody shut about what it will it
broke right you only think Bert
Kreischer [__] reads his recipes I
know I have it's long you know a little
longer than ragu I'm all that it's just
a [__] ice cube leaves that's it and
Segura what the [__] does he read I
don't know okay then so what are you
talking about what is the athletic
challenge this year do you have to wear
bracelets yeah okay back to the
bracelets yeah there's soon's bracelets
okay I gotta see exactly what they do
tomorrow so you put them one tomorrow
yeah it's official on the first
yeah they measure everything oh geez
they draw blood cuz if it's up to Joe uh
uh uh what to my keys I'm gonna find it
and put it back in he was telling me
what's already going to show you we draw
your blood to show that you're clean
yeah but can you be like I'm not gonna
be no I'm not giving it
I don't care what you [__] baby yeah
you know how long it takes me every time
I gotta even think about giving blood I
gotta [__] drive hell yeah I'm like
how I'd [__] that listen the map you
came on I got to see it's been a long
time since you've been on the church I
think the last good one was the acid
church but this was quite as enjoyable I
could see your face and your eyeballs
changing as we speak I'm saying don't
forget me you bad [__] next
week Friday night the Uptown Theater in
Kansas City followed by the next night
at the Paramount Peter first show sold
out we have the second show do what you
need to do Denver come out and support I
did time in your [__] state I don't
care if you got a drive from Gunnison
I'm gonna be in Denver talking about
your beautiful stand I started there I
can't wait to go home I'm gonna [__]
get off the plane and have a big bowl of
green chile
oh that's let's go back and take a nap
the first shows at 7 second shows at
9:30 which one where is it up to
Paramount either I got it okay I got a
[__] 8:30 flight out of out of
Colorado that gets me like at 10:00
something Burbank are you [__]
kidding me or what that means I get up
in the morning go for a bowl of green
chili before the amp when I'll be up
early anyway Kansas City I can't wait
I'm gonna get that night before I'm
gonna go to that kick box at school yeah
that way I went last time my boy takes
it for some [__] barbecue I go too
you know I'm just worried about next
week I'm not even going nowhere this
week this week I'm at the store but next
week in Friday night the 11th I'm in
Kansas City and the 12th I'm at the
Paramount Theater real quick listen
we're a couple of weeks into football
season and there's no better time to
play place a bet you like winning money
correct
who does it I'll tell you where to put
your money down at you ready
my bookie dot AG if you're trying to bet
on the NFL baseball UFC this weekend
whatever my bookies got it not to
mention the NHL and NBA seasons are
right around the corner and unless
you're a [__] [__]
the first month the lines are solved so
it
[__] big money for all you
[__] it starts around the
Halloween my bookie has the faster
payouts and more lines than any other
sports book period they got parlays they
got teaser bets and if you're looking a
little bit you're looking the better
little and win a lot my bookies got your
back they just revamped their site and
it's looking [__] tremendous so I'm
telling you right now to go there and
take a look if you haven't already we're
gonna start with this they're gonna
double your first deposit right now
today use promo code Church CH you are
CH to get 100 percent bonus on your
initial deposit up to $1,000 that's how
we're starting this [__] weekend go
to my bookie right now online today
that's my bookie my B oh okay I eat and
don't forget to use promo code Church
when creating your account listen my
bookie dot AG you bet you win you get
paid the church is also brought to you
by alpha brain on it that's how we're
[__] doing it
listen they're doing a [__] contest
any 30 count or 90 can I bottle of alpha
brain that you [__] buy you got a
raffle ticket you got a little coupon
some [__] jerky but they're gonna
re-enter and then to the grand prize
which is called the island experience
you get to go down there for four days
you get to one on one private they give
you kettlebells they give you a year
supply at total I mean listen Han is
doing the whole thing if I was you I get
into this contest go down at that time
right now press in church BAM I get 10%
taking off and delivered right to your
house
listen I want to thank my bookie I want
to thank I don't I want to thank CBD
lion but most importantly I want to
thank you guys for always having my back
and for supporting Ari and Bray and
myself Lisa I add the next couple years
you guys are [__] troopers I want to
thank Bob willingness and Brian Morton
from Zanies who came out to the show and
said hello you know I love you guys with
all my heart I have a good [__] day
it's so Brock Toba I don't know nothing
about that [__] me I'm gonna keep
smoking reefer so they put me in the
[__]
all right stay black see you in Kansas
City Lee kick this [__] mule